running
let's see here
it says i'm live
let me know leave a comment let's see
here all right we're doing it
hi everybody so good to see you all
again thanks for tuning in give me just
a second as i situate myself here
let me move the camera back
you guys can see that
all right hi everybody um i'll give it a
half you know just like a minute or two
to let more people filter in
um
but anyways so this is the pre-tour of
egypt's live stream i fly out next
wednesday evening
um
i'm on
let me just say something real quick
british airways is so lame they did the
same thing to me this time that they did
to me
last december when i was going to egypt
which is they canceled the non-stop
phoenix to london flight
and this is after they just started up
again um hold on one second situate here
anyways i shouldn't complain but here's
my here's what i'm doing i fly out of
phoenix wednesday evening i fly for uh
to lax so los angeles and then i'll have
a non-stop red-eye overnight flight to
london
um and i'm actually really excited about
it because i'll be on my favorite plane
ever i don't know if you guys know this
i'm a total airplane nerd i used to want
to be a pilot
still be on the triple seven 300
extended range i've never been on triple
seven before but to all you plain nerds
out there it's legit it's 10 feet longer
than a 747 400 i don't know if you guys
care about this but i'm going to tell
you anyway
and uh it has the same wingspan it can
seat 400 people it's
amazing it's a marvel of engineering um
oh everyone's filtering in
awesome um
anyways and then so i land in london and
i'll have like an hour and a half
layover before i have a five hour flight
british airways again of course
uh to cairo and i land in cairo
around 11 p.m or something like that
and uh they'll be on the 30th
and then yeah
i have a whole
uh you know
i won't be able to sleep that night it's
gonna be the same thing that happened to
me last time because i'll hopefully i'll
be able to sleep on the plane but i'll
be so excited and it's a nine hour time
difference from where i live here in in
phoenix
um
so okay hold on people are filtering in
if you guys want to leave a super chat
with a question or comment i i greatly
appreciate it um you'll be hooking me up
and i'll be able to use those funds for
future travels and everything else
because let me just tell you
i do have the travel bug now
many of you know i was just in peru last
month with brian forester and i'm of
course going to egypt with brian forster
again and we're talking about doing a
uh a yucatan uh mexico tour of like
chichen itza and tiawa
so like you know there's a lot of places
in the world now where we you can travel
to
that don't require
that aren't doing the whole mandate
scene
um so
you know to anybody and i've said this
before and i'm going to continue to say
it if you have a desire to travel i
highly recommend you get on it because
this world is changing so fast that
i mean you kind of got to get busy
living or dying at this point because
who knows what the future is going to
hold there are things happening beyond
our control and depending on
whatever your
thoughts and opinions are on certain
things involving mandates you
i i suspect that limitations will
continue i don't know for sure but
oh thank you so much for the super chat
um
does this mean you're vaccinated uh no i
am not i had coveted last year i got in
egypt my symptoms were incredibly mild
um and so
i'm not gonna get on this topic people
got me going last time hey look if you
want to go get the vaccine you go get it
my
i have my own thoughts on it i'm not
going to share in this one um
leave it alone but no i'm not getting it
and i never will
ever
but if you want to get it go get it i am
just not susceptible to covenant and
don't even god damn you guys for getting
me started on that leave it alone um
hold on what do we got here someone
krogdog 101 just gave me 50 bucks what a
j
you're a gangster dude keep it up love
the enthusiasm inside thanks brother
if i ever hey if we ever cross paths i
owe you a beer with that that's very
generous of you
um but anyways let's get off the uh the
the chrome marinade stuff um hey guys
look that's not this is like the most
divisive time probably in history or at
least in recent memory right
um guys we're all in this together it is
what it is
um but anyways all that said you know
there are countries where because
god i'm not i'm stopped just stop right
now
um let's see here what are people saying
so let me keep going with this um these
are coming in we got about
closer to 500 people here hi everybody
so okay let me just say what i was just
saying
flying out next wednesday evening i'll
get to egypt in the late evening on
thursday the 30th and then so on october
1st next a week from today i am going to
do a live stream from the giza plateau
it has the potential to be totally epic
because there's good signal out there
when i was in egypt last november
december i observed that it's
full 3g bars pretty much everywhere in
egypt egypt is very modern who knows it
could be 4g or 5g by now i don't know um
but i had excellent cell service on the
plateau everywhere i was unless you're
in the pyramid itself
so
yeah i got my camera equipment set up
and i am going to do a freaking live
stream and i'm going to take you
everywhere through this
if if i lose signal i'll start the
stupid thing back up again i have a uh
external battery pack so
i i'm gonna make this thing hours long i
cause many people will never be able to
travel to egypt i understand that so i'm
going to do my best to have you live
vicariously through me through my
freaking
camera
and i'm going to show you all of the
things that exist on the giza plateau
besides the pyramids and the sphinx and
i'm going to show you that stuff too
there is so much stonework and relics
and structures that most people do not
have any idea exist around the pyramids
because again the pyramids and the
sphinx get all the attention
but i'm going to show you 120 plus ton
limestone blocks at the top of the
causeway i'm going to show you uh the
nub phenomena these nubs that i've been
showing you on on stonework and other
channels have been pointing out
i'm going to show you guys this stuff
i'm going to walk around the whole dm
place
on a live stream i i think it could
potentially be
absolutely epic um because it's not
until you're out there
let me just say i've researched egypt so
much and it wasn't until i got there
last year that instantaneously you see
like
look at all this other stuff i didn't
even know existed
um
so it's pretty amazing um let me give oh
hold on thanks so much josh randall
for for your uh super chat a month
uh what do you say best 49er i ever
spent dude that's very that's very kind
of you
um
mark ritchie uh see you in egypt on the
first can't wait to talk about atlantis
what up mark can't wait to meet you all
right so that's another thing guys
so i'm only going to be there for the
first four days this is the tour is
october 1st through the 14th
but and i i alluded to this in my last
peru when i did my live stream but i
didn't feel like telling people about it
at the time and to be honest i haven't
even told my friends but my family of
course knows
so
i have a broken knee i have a bone chip
fragment that detached from my left
femur
and i'm okay i'm in no pain at all uh
the first few days was really rough it
was swelled up and and really
crazy but where i'm at now is that
anytime i walk upstairs or i go to squat
at all or put my shoe on in a certain
way it feels like it's going to lock up
and without
i mean because i don't feel like telling
the internet this but i'll share it with
you so i've had five knee surgeries in
my life the last one was in 2014
and i have a rare knee defect it's kind
of more common now almost some
professional athletes have had it but
it's called osteochondral desiccants or
defects where essentially the femur bone
is malnourished from the blood and over
time it can cause like it to chip away
or chip off and die
really gross um so randomly a month ago
i was getting off my bar stool and i
just opened my leg up and there was a
loud pop but didn't hurt at all and it
felt weird the rest of the day and then
the next morning when i was getting out
of bed it almost locked up and i
instantly knew what happened and if
anyone's ever experienced or know of
anyone that's experienced a
a
knee lock up it is
you know it is unreal it is horrendous
it feels like you're if you move your
leg or your your flex or excuse me open
your leg up in any
even for a fraction of an inch it feels
like the whole thing is gonna
because there's a bone essentially
in between the joint and it feels like
the whole thing's gonna shatter it's
really messed up
so because of that there's no
possible way that i'm going to be able
to crawl in or squat to go down inside
the pyramids or other places and there's
a lot of tight spots
so i was going to pull out of the tour
altogether but i really really didn't
want to do that
the whole thing was set up already so
i'm like screw it the first four days
i'll be in cairo where i'm not gonna
need to crawl inside anything actually
um and so when the tour flies down on
day four or five to uh
or to luxor
then i'm just going to go home
it's i want to be depressed about
it but i'm not going to let myself
because here's the blessing i'm not in
pain i'm walking i'm grateful for that
but
um
all the sites that i really really
wanted to get back to
i'm now not able to um
so
but here's the thing i'm one of these
people i'm very glass half full and i'm
counting my blessings and that again i'm
walking my dog every day which is a huge
must last time i had a knee surgery i
was super depressed because i'm not
meant to be
on crutches and caged up and that's the
thing so just to share i've been on
crutches more than a year and a half of
my life in aggregate um
so anyway so where it stands now you
guys are gonna think i'm nuts so i'm
gonna avoid the surgery so this happened
in 2017 a piece of bone broke off again
but i didn't have medical insurance and
i'm like i'm not going to the va and it
was really bad it kept locking up and i
was handicapped it was it was
treacherous but then eventually the bone
moved to some spot in my knee where i
didn't even notice it and then within a
few months it's like it never had
happened and i've been fine since
and so as of right now i know because i
already know the situation i've had two
cadaver so let me tell you with those
five surgeries that included bone chips
breaking off before and having to have
it removed and the other surgeries were
to have two dif these are two this is
years apart cadaver grafts inserted into
each one of my knees so i i have two
dead people in me
so i'm still i feel super i mean that
counts creepy to some people but i'm
super
um grateful for it that i mean
so i'm an organ donor and i recommend
everyone else be too i know some that
creeps some people out but like
because of those people and who knows
who they were and what happened or why
they died
but like because of them like i was able
to
well i wanted to go in the military at
the time and i was able to do that
because of that i was able to go to
egypt and do other things and squat
around so um i'm counting my blessings
so i'll get off that topic but what's
going to suck so bad is that i'm going
to be there i'm going to miss i'm going
all the way 7 000 miles away and all the
sights i need to get back to like the
osiris shaft because i need to film down
on the third shaft where they have the
tunnel blocked off where zahi awasid
stood in front of 20 years ago i need to
film that
i need to get i'm going to miss the base
of the sphinx
because our special access on the tour
allows you to go down there so i'm like
you know that hole in the ass end of the
sphinx that was what i was gonna go down
there and freaking have this huge long
selfie stick and shove my camera down
there and
like what's down there
so anyways um whatever i'll but here's
the good news next february march
looking to go back either with ben of
uncharted x in february or brian
forrester in march
so
um
it could be worse right um so let's see
here lotus 2005 i've already fly in on
the 30th too i can't wait for this trip
take it easy on that knee i know your
struggle
thanks lotus it's very nice of you guys
don't feel bad for me i'm going to egypt
twice
and within a year so and i'm not in any
pain so whatever i'm not i'm just not
gonna think about it
um
yeah
but anyways guys so that being said i
don't
i it might be too late to sign up for
our tour i know we have more than 50
people going
um but if you're looking to do something
last minute it's probably still possible
so go to chemitology.com um if that's
something you're interested in but if
not ben from uncharted x is doing a tour
starting on october 16th two weeks
and so you know if you going a week from
now is too soon and again i don't know
if it's too late it probably is but
maybe not anything
on our last store there's people that
signed up at the last minute were able
to go so
look into it like you know
there's nothing more thrilling in life
than doing something on the fly so
um
that aside uh yeah so next february or
march going back i'll be in full
physical health by then hopefully all
right so that's the thing hopefully i
don't have to have a freaking knee
surgery because i know it's going to
happen i'll go to the doctor and they're
going to want to do another cadaver
graph because i guarantee you that that
well that's what happened the other time
so i want to avoid that because then
i'll be in crutches for months and
anyway
off that topic there's things to talk
about here and and just i'm seeing more
people have of course come in here
so there's a lot of things i want to
mention so to those who didn't just hear
me say it i'm going to do a full live
stream on the giza plateau a week from
today now it's a nine hour time
difference from where i'm at here in
phoenix so realistically if i'm doing it
like let's say two in the afternoon
we'll do the math go you know google
cairo time egypt time
um so it'll be in the morning for most
americans
but either way you'll be able to watch
the watch it after if you miss it live
but guys this has the potential to be
the most epic live stream ever at least
in my book um because i'm gonna take you
all over the plateau and walk around and
show you all the things that you don't
know even exist or at least that most
people don't you're gonna get a 360 view
because it's like we've all seen the
pyramids and the sphinx and everything
else
but within minutes of me entering the
giza plateau i was already learning and
seeing new things i'm like what because
it's there's so much out there and it's
thousands of acres
um so look forward to that and again
i'll be with brian forster on this trip
so even though i won't be there the full
time you'll be with brian and let me
just tell you i had a wonderful 10-day
tour with brian and peru he's a lovely
man he's a true
sweetheart is the way to put it he's a
he has a huge heart he's super nice
and you guys will love him and he's
incredibly knowledgeable
and the tour is also going with patricia
ayan which is yusuf ayan's
uh well ex-wife i probably not my
business to say that incredibly
knowledgeable and she's really into the
spiritual aspect of the egyptians and
she's very informative and has tons to
share
and she's a wonderful person she's the
person that owns the uh kemmet school of
ancient mysticism
um so let's see here by the way real
quick leave me a super chat one of the
reasons why i wanted to do this
live stream was to get ideas from you
guys on what you want me to film while
i'm there on the giza plateau because
i'm of course gonna i'm gonna walk
around the pyramids so you'll see that
you'll get to actually see
what they look like when you're up close
compared to people because you see these
pictures of them and you don't realize
that like the great pyramid of giza was
like a for the size of a 47
story building now with the cap missing
it's like let's say it's something like
43 44 stories
but when you see pictures of it you
don't really realize that until you see
people next to it and realize like oh my
god this thing is unbelievably huge it's
so big that
when you consider that the base of it
is 755 feet wide at each of its base all
over all four sides
well then when you also do the math you
realize that that means that from the
base of the pyramid
to the top
is more than 300 feet away from you from
the base to the center
it's unreal it's so it's an illusion
almost when you look at it um
so anyways let me know what you guys
want me to see but i'm of course going
to circle around the sphinx i won't be
able to get to the bottom of it that's a
special access thing
um but i'm going to show you the all
through the causeway i'll be able to
show you exactly where the osiris shaft
is and here's another thing that i'm
very excited to show you which is all of
the locked gates
um and and doors
throughout the plateau it is unreal how
much stuff there is to see there that is
completely off access to the public
and this tied in if you guys saw my
recent um survey on or or poll that i
did on my community
uh board on my on my channel page
i asked you know because i was want to
see what you guys want to see next and
so i've been working on this video
involving
uh
you know things that have been ancient
sites are being kept hidden from the
public and there's several different
things that i was going to include on
there and one of the things that i
really really want to include and this
is like
the least of my main points of it
is the locked gates and i'm not saying
it's some big conspiracy or anything
like that but there's stuff that's there
that the general public doesn't have
access to and i don't i want to be able
to have access to it even if they want
to charge me i'll pay it
um
all right thank you so much for the
super chat is it by zebly uh send a
drone down to the smaller tunnels if
they will allow it such as the sphinx
tail hole well that has come to mind let
me just say drones are illegal in egypt
or at least on the plateau or around all
the ancient sites cannot use a drone
period um
all right so let me just be clear i'm
not gonna do it so does anyone watch i'm
not gonna do it because i don't wanna
risk getting arrested in egypt
but it's not like that hasn't crossed my
mind to get like some sort of little
remote control car little
you know camera on it and send it down
there but i'd never be that's the thing
you wouldn't be able to get it back it
drops down that shaft on the back end of
the uh of the sphinx
um but anyways
let's see
what do you guys want to ask me here but
uh let me keep going more people are
tuning in let's see so okay well i'll
talk about that in a second um but one
of the other details talking about these
closed sites to so to those of you that
didn't watch my
live stream from after peru and by the
way i see people asking where are all
your videos from proof they're coming
guys i've been working on several videos
at a time i've been caught up with other
things in life as well
and so
the the intention that i have going on
this trip is to just keep my momentum
going and come home and become obsessed
with making videos again like i once was
when i was making videos on a regular
basis when my channel was taking off
like then it's addicting and you can't
stop and then when you losing momentum
is a real thing so that's the intention
guys like there's too many videos that i
have built up that haven't been
finished and so it's time to just get
busy living isn't it
um so look forward to that but um what i
wanted to say though like i was just
alluding to involving what i mentioned
in my last peru live stream is that
guys so listen they're closing they're
in the process of closing machu picchu
to the public
forever
and i'm not kidding here
um
so when i was there last month
if you haven't been to machu picchu or
if you're not familiar with it
the layout that the most impressive
largest stones all the most impressive
structures are at the very very top
you're no you're no longer allowed up
there you can only go down the base of
it like you're on the top of the
mountain
and there's la it's layered
and you know the structures go up
through the layers and the most
impressive stuff is at the very top the
various temples what they want to call
them
um
guys they have guards there you can't do
it it's access denied and we asked why
and they said quote
conservation
so they want people up there
to conserve the site i'm like okay hold
on a second i am completely on board
with conserving ancient sites
great
but if you're not going to let anyone up
there ever
what's the point of conserving it
guys
you can rope these sights off to prevent
you from touching it they have guards
everywhere in i mean like everywhere
they can stop people from scrolling with
it because of course there's been
vandalism and graffiti that have
happened over the years of course
um at all these sites all over the world
too but um
i'm like wait a second so so this is
what they intend to do over the next
couple years
they intend to completely close all of
machu picchu to the public
into where you would only be able to see
it when you so you'll take the train to
machu picchu and you're thousands of
feet below at the bottom of the mountain
and they want you to do a virtual
experience only
i'm not kidding
that's silly that's stupid it makes me
want to boycott the place which i'm not
suggesting yet i wouldn't want to do
that i would not want to do that to the
lovely people of peru
um
but guys something this needs to be
addressed because this is like what the
is the point of preserving this
place if no one's ever gonna be allowed
to see it ever again
leave it to the alpacas in the in the in
the
eagles and hawks what the what's the
point and and again
it's been sitting in the blaring hot
um high altitude sun high altitude sun
is something else you burn it within
minutes out there and the wind and the
rain and all the erosion and the
elements for thousands of years and it's
doing just fine
this is weird so that's going to tie
into that other video because there's a
few other things to discuss
like for example like what about
gobekli tepe
that site was discovered or rediscovered
in the early 90s and they're still like
what's what's the hold up on on digging
this site out it's still only at like 90
percent dug out
i made a video on this one of my first
videos on this was in 2016. we're
talking five years ago
nothing's changed what are they waiting
on what's happening
um
and i mean there's other places too
so i don't know guys i have some real
concerns but that'll make for a fun
video
um
all right so let me keep going what you
guys got to ask me here
let's see here oh let me show you guys
my new camera equipment because okay so
last time i went to egypt it's like you
live and you learn right and a lot of
people were making fun comments or funny
comments to me like when i went into the
great pyramid at the at the end of it
and uh hold on
it's just apple juice don't worry about
it
so i didn't have a flashlight right you
got some of you guys saw that well i did
i just didn't have it on me and the
reason is because we went to the great
pyramid of giza
hours before i was flying out of the
country
and so i had to have all my bags and
everything packed up
so i even left my main camera there it
was like it was the worst time to go to
the pyramid it was too rot
i mean it was a two-hour window but
it was rushed in that like i knew that
as soon as i left i'd have a short span
to go back to the hotel change shower
and get the hell out
so live and learn but the good news is
that i have a few things one i'm
bringing a legit flashlight this thing's
way bit well hold on
why did i do it this is like 350 lumen
it's a good one extra batteries but even
more important than that is this sucker
so this is my mirrorless camera i
believe it's the sony a6600
it's got uh this is the wide-angle lens
it's phenomenal and and i got a legit
light it you can change from different
color of the uh anyways this thing is
far brighter than you'll be able to tell
but this will make all the difference
especially when i'm down there in the
crpm with the hundred ton stone boxes
um
yeah so that's already set up look it's
on there ready to go no big deal
um oh hold on a second
andrew
what up brother
ancient history criticisms if you're not
subscribed to him go go do it right now
he's got an awesome channel him and a
few other channels are you know what
ziggy dan ancient uh his uh history view
uh alternative view excuse me uh phil
and there's a few others um sherman
there's all these wonderful people that
are that are really leading the charge
on the stone nub phenomenon which is all
over peru egypt
dozens of other countries around the
world and they're on it um so he said
here are some backseats for the guards
you bet brother that
is arabic for tips
and tips make a big difference in the
country of egypt i'll say that
let me show you also what i g what i got
guys
well i do have a selfie stick this time
so this thing will be legit for using
with my phone it's got the control
this this will be
a good thing that way i'll when i do use
my phone for some filming i'll
definitely be doing it horizontally
because last time
i filmed in vertical but let me just say
i was not intending on using those
videos on my phone for the internet
and then afterwards i got home i'm like
well i should you know these i got some
good shots but it's like i was filming
in vertical just because i'm holding up
my hand i'm crawling through these sites
you have to be able to
do stuff and
live and learn guys but anyways but
that's not what i intend to use for
filming because what i invested in is
the dgi
uh osmo 2.
this thing is badass this is a 4k
60 frame per second wide angle
video and photo
and this thing is outstanding ben from
our uncharted x has one and if you've
seen his videos the awesome video
quality he has he's using just this
little this little tiny thing
is unbelievably high quality
and i got with it an outstanding
wireless bluetooth
microphone so i'll be using this around
the ancient sites as well
this will make a phenomenal difference
in the quality of the videos of my
channel
something else i have which is nice
nerdy although you're not supposed to
use them in egypt but i got a little
laser pointer which i put i don't want
to point that on my camera like break
something
what's useful about this is that it
helps you to see the quality of uh the
precision of the stone work you
basically flash it along the side of the
of the stone and you see you'll be able
to appreciate how flush it is
in any little blemishes or bumps along
the way this will help you see it there
was a few gentlemen
i believe it was mark from um
where was he from was it sweden or i
believe switzerland could be wrong mark
missed you brother anyways he had
brought one on the egypt trip last year
and it was it was awesome to see that
thing uh so i'm gonna bring that to the
sarah pm and show you guys the precision
of that bad boy oh my goodness kevin
brown 50 dollar super chat thank you all
right so he says
i want to see the polygonal masonry at
the foot of the great pyramid also the
uh the black basalt or whatever is left
of it
thank you so
yes i already had that in mind when i
was doing my live stream i'm like i'm
going to show the polygonal stonework so
the whole
uh
foundation surrounding the great pyramid
is all polygonal flooring it is in some
of these blocks are huge we're talking
10 15 feet wide and all polygonal
interlocked
that is going to be a sweet shot and
then you have the black basalt um i
believe it's basalt polished foundation
that's to the left or
is it west of the great pyramid it's
right there though
and then you guys be able to see like
just how gnarly this stuff is and then
at that same spot you'll be able to see
evidence of ancient stone cutting which
is pretty unreal
um thank you very much kevin that's a
very generous uh super chat um and i
don't want you guys to feel you have to
give me money so let's see let me scroll
through these um
some of these comments
that's andrew that's right jimmy what
thanks brother um andrew you gotta get
to freaking egypt so we all need to talk
like i think we needed to do a a big
group of youtubers
or whoever uh early next year february
march or something
i i think it would be a great thing and
i think we'd all get along lovely in
person too
um all right a headband led light would
work good so i was considering that and
maybe i will i already have one um but
yeah cause like lighting is really
important and let me also say that this
particular camera with this wide-angle
lens is outstanding for low light it did
very well
for uh the pictures i did take while
there but having this light because i
already tested it like a nerd i went
into my garage
at night and
did some experiments and it's like
it was
light as as day um let's see here
history with kaylee hi
thank you so much by the way are you
going to film the causeway and possible
fourth pyramid locations
that ancient architects covered in video
uh three days ago all right i didn't see
that video by the way um
but the causeway absolutely i'm guys let
me just clarify here and to everyone
that's just tuning in right now i'm
going to do a live stream a week from
today on october 1st friday and i'm
going to do the whole shebang it'll
probably take me a couple hours to walk
around this site
well easily actually
um and
yeah i'm gonna show you the causeway and
that's another thing you'll be able to
see just the precision of the causeway
itself you know what it once was
i'm gonna show you on the sides of it so
you
you'll be able to see like guys there's
tunnels under the causeway that's how
you get to the osiris shaft there's like
this hole that goes right under the
causeway and then and then when you're
right here then it goes down
it's unbelievable
um
let's see here
uh but hey guys if you're not following
history with kaylee's channel go do it
right now it's exploding right now she's
i think she's doubled or tripled her
following in the last like
less than two weeks or something and
it's such a great channel she's just
starting to
um so she'll be she'll be a superstar in
no time she's sharing all kinds of cool
stuff and i think it's just the
beginning
um let's see here let me look at some of
these other
comments guys there's so many i'm so
grateful
let's see here
um
let's see
all right andrew the osiris bottom level
has a tunnel running toward the great
pyramid yes that's what i'm saying so
that's what i'm gonna miss since i won't
be there when they go in there so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna partner with
someone there on the tour
and maybe i'll actually i was thinking
about buying
some those fishing trousers that people
use when they're fly fishing and you can
go up to your waist because
the bottom level of the osiris shaft is
completely flooded it's like up to your
waist
but in there there was a tunnel that
extended
zahiawas had a documentary in the late
90s when they were exposing the osiris
shaft and he's standing in front of the
tunnel and saying it goes this way but
we haven't explored it yet which is so
silly like oh
okay you just didn't bother to walk down
to see what was down there like there's
the no like that's not even believable
for a second
so but apparently since like brian
foster had been there a few years ago
they've sealed it up with blocks all i
want is a picture of the sealed tunnel
never mind what's on the side of it i
mean of course that's a unbelievably
important thing to discuss
but it's long been known and said that
there's an advanced tunnel network
underneath the plateau and that would be
evidence of it
and it's sealed i just want a picture of
the sealed tunnel that's all i want
that's the reason why i haven't finished
this video when i was going to talk
about exposing hidden places because i'm
like i need to get back to egypt and
take pictures of some of these other
places
just like at the sierra pm when i was
you know with 100 stone boxes
when i was there in december of last
year the the gentleman running the
facility says according to him that
there's a whole other tunnel of
additional boxes maybe a dozen i can't
remember the number but a whole other
tunnel they discovered in the process of
excavating it now i i don't know if
that's true i don't have any i don't
think he was like making it up or
anything i just didn't see it with my
own eyes and i don't know where that
doorway is that gets there um he sure
didn't volunteer that at all by the way
he was speaking confidence um but he was
a he was a gentleman in fact he could
he's the same guy
oh hold on he's one of the same people
because there's a few that caught me i
don't think guys if you let me just say
real quick if you're not following me on
instagram i mean instagram all social
media is trash guys but it's kind of an
important thing to grow
so if you're not following me on
instagram go find me there it's
it's bright
underscore insight and the reason i
point that out is because i made a funny
post last year when i got home of me
breaking the rules at the crpm i'm
standing on the boxes and i climbed down
below and went into them when i wasn't
supposed to don't get mad at me guys i'm
not hurting these boxes the reason why
it's a rule is because people have
fallen down and broken their legs and
stuff that's my right to go break my own
legs and i know some people and i point
this out because some people got very
upset with me like what are you climbing
on this stuff it's not yours i'm like
because i needed this shot guys i want
to show you guys this stuff
so where i was going with it is that
like he's one of the people that caught
me standing on the box and i had that
posted by instagram but he was a
complete sweetheart
keep in mind i did tip him i gave him
like 20 us dollars which
uh uh the cairo pound or dollar i
believe it's egyptian pound it's 15 to 1
u.s so that 20 bucks goes a long way in
egypt um
so yeah i need the shot and i'm not
gonna stop doing it like until i get
kicked out of that country which i won't
guys i'm respectful like i'm everything
i'm doing there's other people filming
me i'm not i just
people need to know this stuff and let
me just say i'm helping to grow egyptian
tourism
me promoting this stuff is helping
people to sign up that otherwise
wouldn't have gone and i think i should
probably reach out and partner with the
antiquities department to do some sort
of collaboration to maybe it'll take me
some place that's normally off limits
and and and i'm essentially because i've
said this in other videos i tell people
don't bother going to ancient rome or
greece right now i mean yeah go there
those are wonderful places i haven't
been i can't wait to go
but you need to go to egypt and so many
people don't go to egypt because they're
afraid they're like oh you know is it
safe you know i don't know
it's very safe and let me tell you
it the vibe of the place is wonderful
the people are unbelievably friendly but
not only that
it is egyptian law that all tours must
be accompanied by the tourism police and
military you literally have armed
escorts in front and back of the bus
with lights and sirens men with machine
guns and they follow you everywhere
because the last thing egypt needs is an
incident it's happened before years ago
there was an incident with some
vietnamese bus and
tourism is everything for egypt and
they're not messing around it's a very
modern country and just the tempo of the
people themselves i put this way i felt
far safer there than i
than i would in many places here even in
phoenix or new york or other places
chicago my god
um all right so hold on let me just
shout out some of these i just missed a
super trout it was 4.99 from somebody
dang it i'm so so i didn't even see who
it was
i'm sorry
i hate missing that um
whoever it was i want to say thank you
i'll be able to read the comment
afterwards so when i shut down the
stream i'll be able to it's all archived
so here's obi-wan great name by the way
happy to catch a live can you please
tell me what was the best thing you saw
in when you served in terms of moments
well
i mean when i deployed to iraq uh in
2009 and 10
i had the
extremely rare opportunity to see those
ancient um i call them sumerian bulls uh
the the are the lamasu they're actually
um well they're supposed to be a syrian
i suspect they're older and the reason
why i say that is because you got to
look at the nature of how they were
found and they're all found buried in
mud
like many feet below the surface and i'm
like if there's supposed to be a
continuity between the sumerians and the
assyrians which is supposed to be
essentially you know changing
governments and leadership and you know
royalty or whatever
the reason why i think they're older is
because i think it's evidence of the
cataclysm
maybe maybe not maybe and the sumerians
came way after the cataclysm so i don't
even know what i think other than that i
just suspect that they're a lot older
because these things are so big and
massive that if there was continuity
between the sumerians and the assyrians
why would they were they just abandoned
and left to just be covered in dirt over
many many hundreds of years or whatever
i just i think they're older in the
precision of the granite and quartzite
um nature of them
um and and the precision all the details
i'm like to me it looks like evidence of
a
some sort of lost technology and let me
just say technology guys this this is
where people get so carried away it
doesn't have to be power tools guys
technology technology can be a horse
saddle you know technology is anything
that you utilize as a tool to help you
do something else easier so i just think
that there was some capability they had
that has since gone how old and how
advanced is the debatable part
but um yeah to answer your question
obi-wan so samir it's those bulls man
because now they're all gone
isis came in there and literally took um
those uh with those hammers what do you
call them the stupid construction things
and they they obliterated them they got
heavy equipment smashed through them and
they're gone and these things were epic
they were like 15 feet tall
and i only got to see it one day
by complete happenstance so i was
military police and what we were doing
when i was in my year in iraq iraq was
we did a number of things one was
training the iraqi police so we'd go to
back and forth from different iraqi
police stations to give them supplies
train them other things we'd do escorts
we did some other things um and it was
pretty fun to be honest hello
don't get me going i'm completely
anti-war now i think the invasion of
iraq was a complete crime against
humanity
i believe it was a total lie
i know it was but we don't need to get
into that
the veterans themselves we did we were
supposed to do and we believed something
and um some of the best people i ever
met in my life so that's a touchy
subject i want to get going i've gone
down this route rabbit hole before with
other people and anyways
um but anyways it was one day it was it
was in mosul and we were at an iraqi
police station it was directly across
the street from it and we had been going
there for a little while and we had seen
these this ancient site it was the gate
of nergal you should google it gate of
nagal allegedly where jonah from the
bible after he escaped the whale it's
the exact spot he was said to have gone
how wild is that
and when you were there you just knew
you're in the presence of something
amazing this huge ramp to go up and
you're like how many what history
was here you know um all right hold on i
don't want to miss this super chat
um
wilhelmina dutch forgive me if i
mispronounce that me near tooth's grave
i don't is that a picture of you i'm
gonna have to how do i it's not letting
me how do i view your profile
um it's not letting me i'll have to
follow up on that later but thank you
for the for the super chat
um what other questions you all have
let's see here we got 850 people
watching that's wonderful thank you all
um happy friday to those of you that are
new to this i know so those that have
been tuned in you're gonna hear me say a
couple of things same things over and
over again because new people are tuning
in
but uh a week from today october friday
october 1st i will be doing a complete
live stream on the giza plateau and i'm
going to cover everything it's going to
be wild i'm going to show you
all the amazing sights around it and
i think it's going to be like something
you haven't seen before you're going to
see it as if you were there and i
haven't seen someone do that i mean i've
seen brian forrester do some live
streams down there but it's been brief
like minutes just around certain sites
i'm gonna i have this i bought this
brick phone charger
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna go as long as i can i
should have good service
if i get interrupted and it falls out
i'll just restart that sucker all up
again it's gonna be a good time
um let's see here phillip
w herr uh have you ever heard
excuse me have you ever had a sketchy
moment traveling as a civilian
um
no the sketchiest moment
would be
and i'm pretty to be honest with you i'm
pretty on guard when i travel
i have my wits about me i don't let
anyone come up from behind me no one's
ever going to pickpocket me good luck
with that in fact i keep my wallet in my
front pocket when i travel as opposed to
at home i'll have in my back pocket and
i just i just kind of put on this face
like so you guys are going to see it
actually you're going to see it on the
plateau because there are so many sharks
over there
like i said a moment ago the people of
egypt are wonderful but then you have
the scammers and the
thieves and the in the manipulators
around the pyramids that are trying
they're so shy see some of these people
they're trying to get you to buy stuff
or take your money
rip you off in different ways
and they are aggressive they won't leave
you alone they'll come up and i'm mr
nice guy guys i you know if someone
wants to talk to me i'll acknowledge
them i don't like to ignore them like
someone come up and talk to you
and some people just ignore them like
don't give them any attention and i'm
like no that's a human being i like to
at least look them in the eye and say no
thank you
and then i realized
if you're a nice guy and you got a nice
little smile like jimmy and he's like oh
yeah mr nice you know they take kindness
for weakness and they'll prey on you
so you guys will see it eventually you
have to kind of put your guard up and be
like you know
no get back you know like you know
off
um so the sketchiest moments the answer
question would probably be something
like that
but um
i mean i haven't had any late nights out
in like sketchy parts of other countries
or anything i'm pretty smart when it
comes to that stuff no one's gonna get
their one up on me um someone just gave
me 500 is that check is czk check let me
uh let me google this
one second
czk currency i believe that's
oh yeah check there we go thank you so
much mary therese or tris
thank you very much there's no comment
she just it's a tip all right i'm going
to hey that those funds are going to go
towards
um
bribing people on the plateau hopefully
all right let's see here what else we
got some other comments here
by the way
my apple juice but
[Music]
all right all right jimmy trying to be
harrison ford in real life lol viper
chief yeah i mean why not
to be honest like because you guys have
all seen me in that hat
from even being egypt and peru
so that kind of happened by accident i
bought that hat while in denver at an
rei in 2018
this is way before i ever thought i was
going to egypt and i bought it because
it looked so cool and the friends always
with it it's all like jimmy like i just
saw it like it was there i was like
look because i don't even wear hats
anymore i used to wear like baseball
caps growing up and everything but i
haven't wear hats in years at least not
since the military would like make you
as part of your uniform
and my friend's like dude that's a legit
hat you should get that and it's only 50
bucks i'm like all right and then it sat
i didn't wear it once for two years and
then it wasn't until i was going with
ben
of uncharted x to egypt last year that i
was like
this is it i should bring this hat
because you gotta wear a hat out there
you gotta keep the sun off your ears
anyway
um so yeah people are like leaving
comments ever since then like look at
this indiana jones and all that i'm like
yeah
indiana jimmy
thanks uh grim's
doctor
um all right let's see here who else has
a question or comment and let me look at
my list here i've got things i want to
talk about
yeah to all the new people tuning in i
got great equipment for doing lives
i got great lighting this time
and yeah i'm gonna get the shot the only
the crappiest part is that i won't be
there for the full time and the places
that i need to go most i won't be going
back to which is a real shame especially
since i'll be right there
but i'm in kind of a dire circumstances
i even bought a collapsible cane in case
i have an emergency where the because
here's the deal if that knee locks up
it depending on how that goes it might
require emergency surgery so i've
already talked to the chemist school the
people that are running the tour and
they have a doctor contact and all this
so like worst case scenario
of a discounted surgery in egypt i don't
want to believe that will happen because
right now because i'm walking around
fine i don't even have a limp it's like
nothing can happen it's not until i go
upstairs
or i bend my leg or i go to squat or put
my shoe on and like you know bending my
leg that then it feels like that bone is
gonna get in there but other than that
it doesn't hurt at all
you know so
but i'll bring in that collapsible cane
in my suitcase just in case
um
who is it
steven you know do you have only fans i
do not i probably should i should
probably like do a shirtless pyramid
talks right get all you get all you
horndogs give me some money
no i'm never going to do that
let's see here is there a location on
this trip that you didn't get to see
last time well yes but i won't see it
which is at the
base of the sphinx within the pause and
down in there because how they have it
now is that that's a special access
permission you can only go up all on the
top of the enclosure now unless you pay
the fee
so this tour does include that everyone
coming will be able to go down in there
um i will not um but that is which is a
freaking shame too
um hey hang on a second i'm just going
to turn on my ac it's right there it's
only take about five seconds one second
all right i'm back
all right
how are we doing
um yeah and it looks like now here's the
thing like i was just saying that if you
want to make this trip there's probably
still time maybe it's not it doesn't
hurt to send the chem at school an email
but if you would be interested in going
in mid-october on the 16th ben from our
chart x is doing a tour and they are
going to go down
into the depths
of the step pyramid of saqqara
which is one of the most impressive
sites i've ever seen in my life
before when i was studying egypt i
didn't think anything of sakara i mean
it's said to be the first pyramid that
may or may not be true
but this place
when you're inside of it
is unbelievable there's this huge shaft
that just plummets down and
it's wild it's it's one of the most
curious sights i had seen it blew my
mind
and guys he's going down in there so
keep that in mind if that's something
you want to do
here's someone out trist wow haha only
fans you guys are like so i've never
even been to only fan's website what is
that i know it's like people you just
you know be topless or whatever and
um yeah i'm not doing
all you guys are commenting on this
jimmy is way too cool to be doing that's
right i am i'm not doing it like you
imagine those pictures first of all i'm
not in the i'm not doing that it's
i guess it's not porn or what i don't
even know why i'm talking about this
it's funny though you guys are hilarious
kevin brown thank you that's a very
generous
uh super chat
osirion temple now i will be missing
that again that is on this tour the good
news is that when i was there last year
i got i took like 500 photos there i
have every angle of that entire
structure covered so that will be great
for
in future videos because
i don't i mean i want to go back in
there it's one of the most impressive
sites i've ever seen in my life
but like thank god i already i that's
one of the places that i properly
documented
this this last time i mean i really got
the shot thank god
um because that's a blessing guys that
that right there is like something like
two i i don't know the exact number i
heard it was somewhere between two and
four thousand dollars to rent out that
site because now in the assyrion you
can't get down in there unless you have
special access permission and so let's
say 3 000 whatever it was
so you guys that's the benefit of going
on these tours
you have access to the special
permission
so you could go to egypt for so cheap
you get like a you know 800 flight and
you could spend probably a thousand
dollars in country and see a bunch of
stuff
however so some of the best places are
special access which cost thousands so
when you go to big tour it's divided up
so yeah you might spend six grand on a
tour for two weeks which i mean it
includes hotel and almost all the meals
as well as the convenience of
everyone doing everything for you that's
another thing you have people that live
there that speak the language and know
how to grease everything
and and and get you by in a way that if
you went alone you might
because i know people have gone there on
their own and got ripped off on all
kinds of things even taking taxis and
stuff
like it's
so
it's worth it if you can afford it but
you can do things on your own for
cheaper that's you know that's something
to keep in mind but
okay meznet says what's your opinion on
graham hancock's egyptian theories if
true why would the powers that be
covered up well i don't know
specifically what you mean
i mean if i was to say what his theories
are overall it would seem to me that you
know he
and i'm not speaking for him but my what
my impression is that from studying him
of course is that he believes that look
the ancient egyptians were likely older
and more mysterious and advanced than
what we were taught
i'm not i'm not saying he thinks the
pyramids are way way older i've heard
him suggest different things
but i think
here's what i think it's one of two
things either many or some of these
sites that say
are far older and the reason why we
don't have the interest is because the
evidence has since gone away because
we're talking
many thousands of years older than we
thought or
what we thought we understood about the
so-called dynasty egyptians of 4 000 or
so years ago
is
far
more mysterious
than what we thought or that what our
understanding of the egyptians of 4 000
or so years ago is far different than
what we thought and since then the
evidence has been
you don't have to even stay covered up
just gone because egypt has been
rat i mean you talking about
alexander the great went through there
caesars went through there the the
persians like i mean this place has been
completely
for the last few thousand years so much
has happened there that we can't even
properly appreciate or understand and
the evidence is gone because people what
do you think people were doing there
they're being people touching stuff and
breaking and stealing things and
things resting away or god knows what
else um but to answer your question
about graham hancock i think he's right
about far more things than he could
possibly be wrong about i'm not saying
he's wrong about anything i'm not
nothing comes to mind i'm just saying
that like
every single one of us whether it's
nikola tesla or or einstein has been
wrong about actually probably i could
argue wrong about more things than they
were right about
um but i graham hancock is one of my
biggest inspirations i love him i want
to meet him
i think he's a complete gentleman he's
way ahead of his time the background she
has gotten is from people that are
complete have no imagination and and are
are so
god bless their hearts but it's like
they just
it's like they believed everything they
read in some textbook and didn't ask a
single question and it's like how do you
know this you know so i don't know i
don't know if that answered your
question but um because i'm trying to
think of something specific that one of
his theories that you would
um
be referring to i mean i'm right here on
the spot i'm trying to think but um
let's see
here um
yeah this is a great point dominic
johnson there were at least 26 dynasties
before alexander the great you guys know
what a dynasty is
it's like it's like 10 or so pharaohs
it's 26 of them so we're talking
thousand a few thousand years
like
there's so much time that's transpired
between
the time the pyramids were alleged to
have been built for example and i've
heard other people make this point
before and i'll make it again which is
that
cleopatra
is closer to us
than she is to the great pyramid of giza
egypt assuming it was built somewhere
around 4 500 years ago
think about that
guys this is
we don't understand egypt i'm not saying
we don't understand anything i'm not
saying everything's wrong people get so
carried away
um
but yeah i if you want to know what i
honestly think yeah i think it's older
and more advanced than we were taught
how advanced i don't know how old i
don't know i have ideas
come to egypt with me and i'll you know
give me a beer and i'll really open up
that so guys that's one of the funnest
things about going on these tours is
just how open-minded people are you
people from all over the world many
people on the same
opinion on a lot of things whether it's
political or things going on in the
world
conspiratorial or whatever
not all but everyone is on this vibe of
open-mindedness and everyone gets along
and you'll never make friends so fast
either i'm i've made friends from peru
and egypt that i'll be in contact with
from the rest of my life we're talking
great people and the fun part about
traveling at a time like this
is that you're with open-minded people
that are willing to travel when the
world is so crazy right
um
hi diddy i just saw your comment
pyramids under the sand hi diddy you're
wonderful um lego master love your work
keep it up be safe god bless you god
bless you
lego master
that's very nice of you all right let's
see another
um
cyber doc can you bring us back a box of
saltwater taffy if i don't eat them all
and how am i going to get them to you
but yes
what other questions you guys have super
chats were great because they catch my
eye but i don't want you guys to expect
to have to give me money to ask me a
question so i'm looking right now come
on someone ask me something
i'm looking at the chat
it's almost a thousand people here
that's pretty awesome jimmy what are
your thoughts about aliens the moon and
bob lazar okay so
i love it i love this question because i
think about it a lot
okay
a number of things yes i do believe the
aliens have visited earth i think it's
extremely likely i think we're probably
being monitored right now
i think that the moon
if you look at
all right let me see a couple things i
don't even know where to begin on this
i've said this before and i'll say it
again i strongly suspect that humans are
a hybrid species if you go to
not just biblical texts but from various
religious texts from multiple continents
around the world
and you replace words like you know
angels demons sky gods whatever
and and were to say use the word alien
today i think things would make sense
they all talk about someone breeding
with the women here guys what the hell
are they talking about and then you have
humans
i have no doubt related to apes in some
way i mean we have the same exact hair
count as like the as the great ape um
you know like for our head
um dna and other things are very very
similar but not exact obviously um
and we don't assimilate within
environments at all we're like this
cancer spot on earth like go look at a
city from space and it looks like a
cancer blob it really does
um
you know we need shoes and clothes like
we're you know everything else on earth
just assimilates and we don't and on top
of it we're crazy we're just destroying
ourselves all the time and like
just we're mad i i look at us as like
this like this
poor example of a mixed dog breed that
i mean some mixed dog breeds are the
best ever but like there are without a
doubt examples of mixed species out
there that are just
clearly not meant to work out
so
going back to the moon though
there are unanswered questions about the
moon and i don't want to like
mention his name because i haven't heard
this directly but i know people that
went and saw randall carlson recently
he's given these talks
and apparently his thoughts on the moon
are quite interesting i don't want to
speak for him i wasn't there in person
but i will say
that if you go watch my video on the
moon and other things i will i shouldn't
even say his name because
well i will
but it doesn't mean that i agree with
every single thing he said this is how
stupid people are now is that you
mention one person's name like but he
said this just in that so you can't
listen to anything shut up people are
wrong about things right
and i'm not mentioning anything he's
wrong about but i will say this david
ike's thoughts on the moon things that
he has shared in his books which is just
an accumulation of research from other
people like russian scientists and
others
it is very possible that the moon
is somewhat artificial in that it has
been hollowed out
and is is an example of intelligent
design and without me mentioning other
people's names because it probably won't
be appropriate for me to speak on their
behalf but there's other extremely smart
credible people out there
from what i hear
have the same opinion
but they're careful on what they share
publicly
and
guys it's wild like there's so many
things about it that are unbelievably
different from any moon in our
understanding of the solar system or any
research we've done from any other
observed satellite moons
in solar systems you know far away
i know that sounds wild it sounds crazy
to people the first time they hear it
but if you really dig into it it kind of
it's it's possible is all i'm saying and
if you saw my moon video from a year and
a half ago or whatever it was
all i'm saying
is that we should go back there and i
want to see some really good you know 4k
video that's all
that's all that's all i'm asking i mean
china's on the dark side of the moon
right now and you hear anything about
that what are they doing
apparently they're like trying to go
vegetables there and mushrooms and crap
you hear about this that's mainstream
news by the way most people have never
heard that there are things happening on
the moon that we are not aware of
meanwhile there's this huge space race
between russia china and the united
states to go mine the moon for precious
metals and other elements that are rare
on earth or
just worthy of a worth a lot of money
you don't hear anything about it anymore
do you they're doing it they're in the
process of trying to make that happen
right now you don't hear anything
nothing to see here
meanwhile everyone just watches the news
all day long and whatever's the
the the mainstream headline at that time
is all they focus on
and then you lose track of all these
other things that are happening behind
the scenes
so
something fun to think about don't get
me going go watch that video because
there's been lights observed from the
moon
some people say well that's you know
those are from the mirrors they put up
there on the apollo missions no there
was lights observed hundreds of years
ago and thousands of years ago on the
moon this has been documented there's
thousands of cases this is real and nasa
has documented this in extensive
uh documentation what i'm trying to say
it's real it's called transient lunar
phenomena it's a real thing
right before the apollo 11 the day
before the apollo 11 astronauts landed
on the moon for the first time ever
uh houston had radio to them say hey we
are observing this green fluorescent
lighting on this crater on this you know
corner of the moon blah blah immediately
michael collins radio back and says
we're observing it now the
green light on the surface of the moon
so out of all the things you heard from
the apollo missions how many people are
aware
that they saw a freaking light on the
moon before they landed
isn't that like a front page headline
itself you guys this is document this
isn't like hearsay this is nasa records
this is a real thing
it's unexplained so what was it i mean
there are theories male 1 gas
but that's another thing so why is there
gas escaping from the moon there's
seismic activity happening it's supposed
to be a dead plant alright hold on
michael wiggins what are your opinions
as to uh as far as the safety or risk
for non-straight tourists in the middle
east i've only heard bad stories people
exaggerate okay here's the deal all
right if you want to be completely
honest and this is from my own
experience in egypt as well as the
military being trained on certain things
so here's the deal in many mideast
countries yes it is socially
unacceptable to be
homosexual but there are many people
that are but just you know better off
being dll about it i guess
um but i will say this and this is guys
i've heard this directly okay like
you know there is many people there are
many more people that are homosexual
there than most people are aware and
many of the people that are against it
are homosexual themselves are just
trying to not have
religious conflicts and things with
their parents um
put this way if i
look i think people should just be
themselves like if i was gay i would i'd
probably be mr proud about it and just
wait for somebody to cross my path and
mess with me because like you know i'd
be the guy to punch their lights out or
or try or die trying because i'm like
for somebody to hate on you for
that it's like that's no different than
being racist like you're born gay like
you don't just decide to be gay right so
it's like for someone it's like no
different than someone calling go up to
a black person saying the edward that's
the way i see it um and so that's just
stupid but but we all know like it's
still a taboo thing in much of the world
it's becoming far more socially
acceptable out you know and especially
in the states in the western world but
it's still kind of a thing in some
places like hence you're asking right i
don't know whereabouts you live
but what i will say is this i have no
doubt that there that there was i mean
i'm assuming some homosexuals
on my trip to egypt they were there was
no issue there i don't remember them
like going on dates or anything but like
the point is is that i don't think
you'll have any issue why would you
but maybe
if it might be smart not to like be
too out there about it either but either
way if you're on a tour
ain't nothing gonna happen to you one
you're gonna be with a huge group of
people that will be looking after you
plus you have the tourism police and
three like the people out there aren't
that bad guys like i don't know i hope
that answers your question but i guess
if i had to give you a straight answer a
straight answer no pun
there's you have nothing to worry about
so
let's see here oh let me just remove
that mean comment from this
mean person let me see if i can block
them forever too
um
yep
blocked
um i don't know why somebody would come
to my
channel if they don't have something
nice to say it's like hey go somewhere
else there's plenty of other things to
talk about uh or other people to hear
things from
but anyways um so what else do you guys
want to talk about let's see here let me
look at my list
um
oh i want to talk to you guys about the
tour itinerary people were asking
earlier about where we're going so here
we go
day one october 1st
and this will give you guys an idea
especially if you're thinking about
going on a tour you'll understand how it
works so for a 14 day tour this is how
it goes down
it officially begins on friday october
1st at 6 pm people are meeting at the
hotel and we're doing an introductory
dinner and meet and greet you have
everyone meet up in a big circle and
everyone there's an introduction from
the tour host
you know explain a bunch of things about
what to expect while we're there and all
that
and essentially
they everyone will go around and just
briefly introduce themselves like you
know hey here's who i am we're you know
where i'm from why i decided to come
here here's what i've been open to
discover and just share anything they
want and it's so awesome it's a great
icebreaker some people are shy speaking
in front of others but by the end of it
you feel great and everyone's so
welcoming and supportive
um so there's that and we'll have an
excellent dinner and then saturday the
second we're gonna go tour the giza
plateau so maybe i'll do another live
stream there depends how it's going down
people will probably want to chat so
that's why i want to do it friday before
the tour starts while i'm going to giza
plateau and i have my own time
so we're going to go around but we're
not going into pyramids that's at the
end of the tour which is why i'm going
to miss that again
um but we're also going to visit um the
valley temple which is in front of the
sphinx it's one of the more impressive
sites in hall of egypt it's very similar
to the assyrion so i'll get to see that
and then we're having dinner and then on
october 3rd sunday
we were we're going to okay so the grand
egyptian museum was supposed to have
already been opened last year they keep
pushing it back
because they're covered and all this
other stuff but so that's not open yet
but it's like i don't remember i want to
say it's like a million square feet it's
right in front of a great pyramid
one of i believe i could be wrong but i
believe if i remember right it's one of
the biggest museums ever built
unbelievable it's not open yet so
instead we're gonna go back to the cairo
museum which is where i was last year
but i have no complaints because that
was one of the coolest buildings i've
ever been in it's built like 1905. it's
huge marble flooring must be four
stories tall i mean it's two stories but
it's so grand
it's huge and and it's there's it's so
big and there's so much in it that you
could literally spend weeks in there i
was in there for four hours and i didn't
see everything
amazing so we're going there
and
oops i'm sorry
that's on monday i i missed
sunday which is when we're going to
saqara to go into the pyramid of unis
the unes pyramid which is the only
pyramid in egypt that has any type of
inscriptions in it but it's clearly not
original because it's
on plaster that was put over the stone
the stonework is unbelievably impressive
and then you have this
still impressive but not anywhere near
on the level
of um
of uh glyphs that are essentially carved
into plaster that was put over it so
we'll see that
and be in saqqara and then from there go
into the serapium
the 100 ton stone box is all 24 of them
i believe
um
and then hold on one second let me just
double check the chat because i was
hold on here i was clicked off this link
i'll go back to reading more of the
schedule in a second i don't want to
miss any super chats
what are you guys asking me here
while you're there will you be taking
pictures of the worldwide polygonal
masonry you're damn right a whole bunch
of them too
uh pictures i'm gonna be filming this
live stream guys you're gonna see it
with your own eyes um
guys look at this guy oh oops
oh my god guys don't get into politics
on here in the chat you silly people
come on guys we're all here because we
have this one thing in common which is
this awesome
uh
fascination with the ancients so
hold on to that otherwise you could
spend your whole life just finding
things to disagree with people on
anyway so on monday the fourth is when
we're going to the museum
and that's when the rest of the group is
flying down to luxor and then i'm going
to the
hotel
or the airport hotel
and i fly out the next morning
what a shame
but
here's what everyone else is doing on
october 5th tuesday
they are going to dandera and they're
going to the hot the temple of hattor
which is
maybe my most favorite place in all of
egypt
it is spectacular
it was people that i know that went
that met multiple people that have been
to the sistine chapel which is amazing i
have not been personally but they said
that this place like literally eclipsed
it the the stonework the paintings on
the top it's unbelievable and it has a
really good vibe to it
um
so they're going there
and then
let's see here
forgive me
okay blah blah blah okay
the on wednesday the 6th they're going
to the temple of seti in the assyrion
it's going to be amazing that the tell
god i miss this assyrian is one thing
amazing and the temple of seti actually
really surprised me i love that place
and by the way there's evidence all over
the over there of of the egyptians doing
dmt
what through the lotus flower
facts something i didn't know until it
was there but once you see it and have
other people explain it to you
zero doubt in my mind 100
the egyptians were doing dmt on the
regular
100 100
um the good news is i have tons of
pictures from that so i'll make a video
on that at some point
um and explaining my own dmt experience
oh by the way i forgot to mention
because i'm looking here on the
itinerary geologist susan moore is going
to be there on the trip i'm forgetting i
haven't met her yet i've seen so many
videos with her with brian forrester
incredibly smart woman been doing this
her whole life and a complete expert in
stonework in geology
wonderful person have go and she's very
open-minded so i can't wait to meet her
uh what a treat
all right so on the ninth that's next
saturday hold on where am i at was that
friday okay excuse me on friday they're
going to be going to the temple of
karnak oh god i wish i was going back
there
saturday let's see they're going to edfu
oh
god
temple of horus
oh my god
i'm missing out and they're also going
to sobek and come
come commambo that's one of the places i
kind of didn't even know about until i
went to egypt the first place but i'll
keep going with this forgive me i'm
trying not to bore you guys telling you
about this tour but you get an idea what
it's like to go on a two-week tour of
all these sites
okay so going forward to that monday
they're taking a motorboat on the nile
to the island of fellais which is one of
the coolest places i've been
um you would think you're in the middle
of the mediterranean out there it's why
it's just amazing and then they're going
to the temple of assets
the isis temple or that was recreated i
believe um and they're having lunch
uh well it doesn't matter let me keep
going on tuesday the 12th i'm almost
done here are they going up the nile
river
and they're going um they'll be at the
same place that from uh raiders of lost
ark was filmed and some other spots but
they're gonna
let's see here
um they're going to tannis
wonderful i'm missing tannis evidence of
the cataclysm guys and lastly i'm
wrapping this up forgive me but i want
to share all this on the 13th wednesday
at the end of the tour basically they're
all going to the valley temple and
they're going to go into the spas
positive sphinx
and then uh following from there they're
going to have a great pyramid and then
day 14 which is an extra day which is
optional people will be able to go into
the osiris shaft because not everyone
likes going down there it's literally
the creepiest place you can imagine the
creepiest place i've ever been in my
life is the osiris shaft not just
because it's 100 feet underground and
it's dark
but like i stepped in human bones down
there like this place is littered with
centuries of history that hasn't been
cleaned up and who knows whose bones
those were my god
um and there's something about it like
like the pyramids have a good vibe the
temple of hot tour has a good vibe
the cairo museum had a really weird vibe
it was a bit depleting
some people don't understand how vibes
work it's a thing not everyone has to
agree with it you think it's woo-woo
fine
but um i'm convinced
but um
the osiris shaft was i was in there for
30 minutes
and i left i want to get out of there it
had a terrible feeling guys i felt that
way in the valley of the kings too
surprisingly i wasn't expecting that
okay lettar lindfest i can't pronounce
that but it's czech thank you so much
it's generous you said hello jimmy
whenever i talk to mainstream historians
professors and so on about a pre-flood
civilization or human beings then we
think hold on
i feel like you cut off you may have hit
send before whenever i talk to
mainstream historians professors and so
on about a pre-flight civilization or
human beings being older than we think
um i don't know where you're going with
that but i'm sure they don't believe it
here's the bottom line there was a
cataclysm called the younger driest
climate catastrophe of 12 13 000 years
ago that's science
if that happened today it would be
civilization ending it would not be an
extinction level event but yes it would
cause mass extinctions of various
animals and of course
regions around the world for people
would be inhospitable from that point on
people were alive at that same period of
time so yes this event is real if 75 of
all mammals in north america died at
that same period of time humans would
have too it's there they don't want to
believe it there's no evidence there is
evidence gobekli tepee's evidence 12 000
years old
oh
oh don't get me going
it's so fun chatting about this stuff
all right nemo nova good morning or
excuse me good journey to you uh fellow
traveler i'm one of your patrons thank
you so much all my generous patrons got
patreon
followers guys
i'm not asking but if you you know all
that support goes a long way with me oh
and i want to mention
so i set up a venmo venmo's like this
big thing now right everyone uses venmo
so if you look in my description i have
my username on there i just set it up
recently which reminds me wells thank
you so much for being my first donor he
knows who he is what a generous
individual
helps get me some of this camera
equipment by the way um so it's bright
underscore insight it's pretty awesome
if you want to just tip me there because
you like what i'm doing great if not i
love you anyway um
all right so he said we look forward to
hearing from you when you get back you
bet hey guys that's the plan i've said
this before for you you know those of
you that have been following me for a
long time but this is the opportunity to
get my momentum back you know momentum
is a real thing and now it's like now i
just need to get back on my grind and
make videos non-stop it's really hard
when i take breaks
because then it's like because what i do
it's not easy like there's a lot of
effort i put into to creating these
videos i do it all alone i'm not great
at editing it's actually my least
favorite thing to do in the world maybe
which is one of the things holding me
back i was looking for an assistant for
a long time but nothing panned out
so now it's time for jimmy's man up and
get this on the road the show on
the road right
not jackie chan we love you jimmy thank
you for your awesome channel i think
aliens were humans who left the planet
long ago before cataclysm so hey
i have a thought just an idea
what if what if the moon is the ark
because i kind of think that may have
happened now hold on i'm not convinced i
can see it now oh jimmy's insane
he's convinced that you know humans left
the planet earth thousands of years ago
what a you know he's a crackpot
pseudoscience ah
guys anything's possible you don't know
what the hell happened here ten thousand
years ago you don't you you don't
um
and it's fun to talk about nonetheless
so that's one reason to come on these
tours because then i open up big time
i'm careful what i say on the internet
because like you got to be you know
i want to be responsible if i say
something like it's a certainty some
people might just believe it because i
said it i would like to think most won't
because people think for themselves
people are smarter than people give
credit to
but you know
but if you don't know what i really
think come on a tour
because then you know put like two beers
in jimmy and he'll open right up um
michael wiggins they've discovered a set
of ruins older than gobekli temp uh
tepee now we're at please tell me um
a atheizi
incredible content live
from ethiopia thank you
um
and speaking of live so i don't know
what time it is out there in ethiopia
must be nine or ten hours ahead right
now
so what i'm in egypt it's nine hours
ahead of phoenix so let's say
that'll be six hours ahead of new york i
believe
um
so when i do that live stream it's hard
to say what time i'll start but
let's say 2 p.m 3 p.m in the afternoon
at the latest
so be a little early for many people out
here but never made me think about that
um let's see here
shut up mystery man that's not nice you
didn't even spell it wrong you didn't
even spell ethiopia right so joke's on
you love you all though by the way
um let's see here
thank you matthew rubio the historian
herodotus talks about a giant labyrinth
south of the pyramids have you heard
about it yes i've been there on the
ground that's above it it's said to be
there and there was
it's all buried now but there's tons
and when i say tons i'm talking
countless millions of pottery shards all
throughout
it looks like a huge wave of
of mud went over it if i'm being honest
and there was if there was one spot that
had the most
military and guards around us it was
there and it wasn't for our safety they
were watching us
it's there there's there's said to be a
labyrinth there that's like known like
it's i mean this is some science this is
science by the way um and
out of all places that they were like
watching us like hawks
yeah so
and there's said to be some there's
underground tunnels and uh chambers
underneath the giza plateau let me tell
you
yusuf ayan's father
akim
when he was a kid he went in an eight
mile long tunnel that went from
to the great pyramid he did it
um
it's closed off now there's no evidence
i mean i can't prove it to you but like
he did it he adamantly said that hey
that's what i did and
so
that's the thing guys why would they
cover this up why would they prevent
people from like discovering this and i
what i think is if if you want to know
if there was some real conspiracy here
i'll i'd say that i think it's very
simple in that maybe it has to do with
that you know
egypt is an islamic country where the
government and the laws that exist in it
are islamic in nature
and
if there was ancient evidence that came
to light that would essentially debunk
or
contradict that you know religion itself
there you go that's my best guess or
they found some underground stuff and
there's tons of loot in there and money
and gold and treasure and they're just
just
you know siphoning it to all hell and
and right you know
that's another idea too
a feasi i've got another one here says
they obviously don't have dictionaries
wherever you're from mystery man oh
spend five dollars just to show him up
easy don't worry about him and he don't
mind those jokes you're a wonderful man
and the joke's on him and mystery man i
love you too guys don't be silly with
each other but that is funny pay five
dollars just let someone have it well
done
um
all right someone's asking me ernest
suarez jimmy will you ever visit mexico
pyramids this is why i like to repeat
things i said this earlier in the in the
live stream which is that yes so i want
to put on a tour to go down to
um
the
uh
the yucatan excuse me which is you know
southern mexico not far from cancun a
couple hours from there and go to
chichen itza as well as go more west
over to tiawa khan
i want to go to mexico for a number of
reasons you don't need any
uh testing to get in there or any
erection or anything like that they're
not even enforcing masks
i want to go someplace like that um you
go wherever you want to go
that's where i want to go and i've never
been and i've been hearing so many great
things about mexico when i was growing
up especially being from phoenix you
hear weird things especially along the
border you know because there's cartel
and other stuff
what i learned there's this lovely woman
claudia uh that i met in peru that was
on the tour with her husband richard and
um wonderful people by the way and she's
from mexico and i think it was her that
told me that like you know cancun is so
safe because i don't know if it's true
and i don't even remember if it was her
that told me i just that's what i think
that like the cartel close or controls
that whole area down there in cancun the
resorts
and it's super safe for a reason because
like that's their that's their money
they ain't gonna allow any
crap go to go down there so anyways long
story short yes i want to go down there
within a year i want to i want to be
there
sooner rather than later
um
all right guys who else has a nice
question here or super chat or comment
yep someone wrote alex city that's true
cocoon is controlled well i've heard it
from more than one person it has to be
it's
yeah i believe it
good good control and keep me safe
that's all i care about um
what do you think about the shakespeare
authorship debate i
ozzy mondias i uh i love that name
that's
epic i don't even know if i know i think
i'd have to google that guys i don't
know if i'm familiar
all right we got andrew with something
else again ancient historian criticism
coker pyramid and cambodia oh dude
uh
yeah that's i need to go to cambodia
that's another one
let's see
here thank you discomfort
for the generous gift also darren you
guys are so nice
um
let's see
could the sahara desert have been the
garden of eden eden yes if it wasn't
mesopotamia then it was there because
here's what we know 5 000 or so years
ago the sahara desert was a green lush
tropical paradise consisting of a
extensive network of rivers as well as
the largest freshwater lakes ever known
to have existed on planet earth
and it's right next to egypt
people were there and let me just say
there's mainstream scientific articles
that said the same thing that it would
have been where people had lived
my video on um
uh
what's buried uh hidden under the sahara
desert i think is among my better i mean
the the atlantis richard ones are fun
not everyone believes in that but if i
think if there's one video that i
is my go to to recommend to other people
it's that one i think
i'm proud of myself for it and there's
something there
that the sahara desert is
the ancient gold mine
for ancient historical facts and mark my
words they're already they keep finding
new stuff there and they're doing it
through satellite um they're doing
archaeology from space they're using
lasers and lidar from space
and they're finding ruins that aren't
supposed to exist out there
and they're and they don't even know who
they're from some of them
um yeah guys like it may so whether it's
the garden canadian of eden who knows
but there's something there it's just
like
like the doggerland
uh area uh you know
in the northern sea next to you know
east of england like there's they know
that there's pottery and other things
have been found in the in the ocean down
there and it's like what who's that from
they don't what's that about
there's all kinds of mysteries around
this world so let me see what else we
got here you guys are very nice how long
i've been going for
it says 81 minutes we got a thousand
people on a little over a thousand you
guys are awesome
um so nice hey hit the hit the thumbs up
if you haven't i guess it doesn't even
matter i don't care i mean i am i am
grateful for anyone that hits a thumbs
up um
will you go to mauritania okay so here's
the deal
i want to say yes
my buddy matt that i went with to egypt
and peru
if i go with anyone he's going to be
there
my friend josh gerson went there
guys it is dangerous
logistics
okay
josh almost died when he went there one
you had to drive through a land
an a legit old land mine field
and they saw actual skeletons of people
along it
the logistics of carrying enough food
and water so they were starving out
there um because you're in a legit third
world country where you can't just like
buy food like you can other places they
had a choice at one point when they were
so hungry because they were depleting
their supply they had to eat either
rotten goat goat
which they declined
or like they were eating leaves dipped
in olive oil just to put something in
their bellies so it had if to do it it'd
have to be done right i'd have to
partner with the local government
um there's other issues too where the
it's illegal to do any type of ground
penetrating radar which is one reason
you want to go there to see what's
buried under the damn sand
oh
i don't think anything would be found in
and around the wrist shot if it is the
actual location of atlantis which is to
me i
think it's the most likely location i
know there's doubt it might not be
i i know it might not be
but it is worthy of further study and i
think it's just far too fun to
to not pursue that
but i think the area that would need to
be researched would be the area west of
the wrist shot
in the 250 mile range between there and
the atlantic ocean the coast and at that
atlantic coastline it drops off almost
immediately a thousand feet dip deep and
then in the miles that go
beneath it we're talking like 13 000
feet depth 11 thousand feet it's wild if
you're gonna find any ancient blocks it
would be out there i think or in the
buried who knows how many feet under the
ocean or excuse me the dirt before the
ocean
that's would be the place to look but
then by then if you know if those blocks
got let's say a huge wave brought and
like moved all those whatever structures
over that stuff would probably be
pounded down to dust by that point um
hold on let me read these um
super chats before they go away all
right history caleb give me another one
would you do a tour in europe to see the
ancient mounds hinges and the domains
and dolmens
i could translate the dutch uh yes
absolutely history history with kaylee
maybe we should set this up we're going
to do a collab we talked about that i
was thinking maybe
uh when i get back from egypt we could
do a post-egypt live stream together or
something like that but yes absolutely
um let's talk about that um discomfort
we know about the nubs but could you
know about the clamps oh yeah there's
evidence worldwide maybe while you're in
egypt yes i'll ex i'll i'll document
that extensively
thanks for the for the second super chat
ali halford
or ollie thank you for your vids great
to catch you live been a fan from early
on came to hear your thoughts on bob
lazar and jeremy corbell i love them
both bob lazar okay
before i answer your question let me
read off this live this super chat from
kdc before it goes away good luck and be
safe on your travels
uh keep it up uncovering the truth thank
you katie
very sweet of you i appreciate it okay
here's the deal i believe bob lazar is
telling the truth however
my own gut instincts i i he may have
exaggerated on some things and or may be
some of the knowledge that he has shared
i think he may have heard about from
third party however
i might be wrong on that i'm not trying
to discredit him i'm just trying to go
into this from you know an open mind
um let me have a little sip here of my
apple juice
he said things that were fraudulently
debunked for example he said that he
worked at s4 they end up or at the um
where is it besides s4 at the los alamos
whatever facility
and
the government came out and said no he
didn't he never was there and then they
come out someone else who had worked
there provided the catalog that shows no
he had an actual contact there or his
name and phone number was in there he
did work there
and they lied and said he didn't that
right there gives him credence
and because of course if he was
literally a whistleblower somebody
coming out that was you know we're
talking
area 51 top secret stuff came out and
exposed stuff of course they're going to
discredit him that's what that's what
any entity would do or if they're okay
with lying
so i think he's telling the truth
overall it doesn't mean that he didn't
exaggerate in some things i'm not saying
he did i'm just trying to go into it
with like you know
being on my guard but
guys he knew specific dates that there
were there was these testing being done
with the aircraft and they got nick's
red-handed he didn't how would he guess
that so either he knew firsthand or
somebody else told him
that that's what was going on either way
he knew something that turned out to be
true and they did everything they could
to try and bury this guy
so i believe him
alexandra johnson hi jimmy are there any
theories you're hesitant to speak about
online but love discussing in person and
would you ever come to texas laugh out
loud not to explore just for fun well
yeah i want to come to austin i've never
been i've been through dallas and
houston houston sucks
i love well i've had fun in houston but
anyone that lives in houston forgive me
for saying that but they all say the
same thing everyone i've ever met from
houston's like you know they're living
there for work whether it's the oil
industry medical field or whatever and
like you know this place sucks but
there's some fun places down there in
houston like was it washington avenue
leave a comment if you've been there um
yeah i'd love to come to austin i've
heard great things
but to answer your question alexandra um
well
okay i'll just say it i i'm when it
comes to the moon i think there's
something there
and by something i mean that the general
public doesn't have you know access to
like to be completely blunt i don't
think the question is whether we've been
to the moon i think the question is
what's the when is the last time we've
been there and what did we find if i had
to bet real money on this i would
literally bet that a human being has
stepped foot on the moon
since the last apollo mission in 1972. i
actually think that and if that's not
true i think then that various drones or
robotics of some kind has since been
there to do exploration that we're not
aware of i
i bet on that
um
also
i mean yeah besides thinking that humans
are hybrids i that that's what my gut
says i could be wrong i don't know that
i bet on it um and yes i do all right so
let me give you an example if you really
want me to get some some conspiratorial
thing because here's the question
or when it comes to
conspiracy theory involving ancient
history i do not think for a second that
there's a vast conspiracy involving so
many academics and whatever i think most
people were taught something and they're
going on to repeat it
and didn't ask enough questions along
the way
however if there is some sort of
cover-up some people maybe a small
amount of people are in on it and i
think that's quite interesting that some
of the most powerful people on earth
have a fascination with the egyptians
for example
let me because this is touchy um
did you know
all right so let me uh let me i gotta be
careful on this
i would argue that the pharmaceutical
companies the biggest ones are the most
powerful entities on earth now they are
kings whether it's their control over
politicians and the media these people
have done it
no one has been more successful with
than them
so much so that they're above the law
this is true
and
they certain pharmaceutical executives
and companies
have given
their families i should say have given
enormous amounts of money towards
egyptian antiquities and museums around
the world in support of ancient egyptian
antiquities i don't know if you know
that let me give an example the purdue
family
purdue pharma you know the ones that
lied under oath about the opioid
epidemic the create the creators of
oxycontin
if you haven't seen it go watch
the pharmacist
four part documentary series on netflix
this guy uh phil schneider or richard
snyder or um
if you forgive me for getting anyways it
doesn't matter this wonderful man a true
hero a true hero
had was a pharmacist and he had exposed
what he was seeing and he's one of the
reasons he'll bring this these people
down or at least
i
don't know these none of these people
really got brought down but anyways that
documentary receives my highest
uh recommendation and go watch it and
then there's a part in it in the last
you know episode where they share that
this purdue family was like really
invested in egyptian antiquities now
maybe they're just a bunch of nerds like
me that are into it or maybe maybe just
maybe they've paid to know because let
me give you another example how is it
that the
underground mummy the black market from
for egyptian mummies is a 4 billion a
year industry that's a mainstream uh
news article
figure by the way
the ufc was like four billion or is
which is one of becoming one of the
biggest sports uh the nfl is something
like a seven bill or maybe it's seven
billion now excuse me nfl is seven
billion as well i believe usc and nfl
are competing at this point uh because
with all the lockdowns and everything
like ufc has really blown up but here's
where i'm going with that if you have
the whole nfl being like a seven billion
dollar a year industry which is seems
like it's going down by the way they're
losing viewers and money and other
things
and you're talking about four billion
dollar a year just to put in perspective
that means that some of the rich who do
you think is paying this money for these
mummies
and other various relics from ancient
egyptians we're talking about the
richest most powerful people on earth
that have actual
like real disposable income
that are buying this up
and they probably have their own little
museums in their basement and god knows
what they're doing they're probably
having like people over in the drinking
brandy and like come down here look at
look at this pharaoh that i this dead
pharaoh i have buried in my basement or
you know on display
so
yeah
i don't know i hope that answers some
questions that gets you thinking
michael wiggins article sent via
instagram link is my name i'll go
looking for it i'm not trying to sound
cool guys but i kind of get blown up on
instagram especially any time i post a
story i'll get
i'll get 50 responses and it buries it
and i don't look at it all the time it's
kind of exhausting i don't
go follow me on instagram but i don't
keep up on it enough it's just a little
difficult for me i don't know if i just
missed somebody's super chat but let's
see here i got one from vector force
20 and just just a tip thanks brother no
question no comment that's very nice of
you
um what else do you guys want to know
and talk about i'm on a roll here
hopefully well let me see it's not
showing me my phone battery but i'm just
going to keep going
yeah
what are you guys saying
[Music]
who's got a
who's got a question here
anyone else got a super chat i don't
want to ask you guys from many but i
have seen him bill gates did you guys
see bill gates recent uh
defense about his dinners with that
scene let me just tell you something
because all right guys so i was a fraud
investigator for a
a large corporation let's say fortune 30
or so at least it was at the time and i
would used to investigate external theft
or excuse me internal theft and fraud
and i would manage a team that did
external theft
and so i'd bust like salary managers and
stuff that were defrauding the company
hilarious
one of the most fun gigs i've ever had
and one of the things i was always good
at like picking up on lies from from the
get-go i used to help like friends like
expose like
cheaters like dude i'm like dude your
girlfriend's cheating on you trust me
look at the way she wrote of that text
she's lying
funny stuff like that i wasn't always as
good about it directly if i'm like you
know in a relationship and like you you
know you kind of give people benefit of
the doubt but when you have when you're
separated from somebody you kind of just
sense it i was good at that
and one of the things i noticed is that
when people are truly innocent they
don't apologize they say i don't know
what you're talking about i didn't do
anything what do you what and then bill
gates is apologizing saying oh well i
shouldn't have done that how because i'm
talking like him are short of uh you
know had uh
dinners with that scene it's like why is
one of the richest man on earth asking
epstein for money he's like i was just
there there's an investment you know
money for funding
why are you asking anyone for money for
one of the richest people on earth and
why are you having multiple dinners on
his jet and then why are you apologizing
for it if i was him if i didn't do
anything wrong i would say excuse me
excuse me i didn't do anything wrong
here i understand all these allegations
that have come out against them which is
disgusting but i was guys listen i'm
involved in all these investments for
the scientific research and i mean yeah
i mean knowing what i know now yeah
great i would love to have not been uh
affiliated with him but you know leave
me alone i don't care like i i didn't do
anything wrong
but he's apologizing i know i shouldn't
have done that like what
okay what shouldn't you have done then
if you knew he wasn't up to no good you
should have a clear conscience
he's admitting guilt he's guilty of
something you can see in his mannerisms
he's way
too physically obvious with how he's
reacting go watch his interviews it's
like from a day ago or two days ago
maybe um yeah he's that he's guilty of
something should i be talking about this
um
rick johnson oop hold on it went away
where'd it go let's see here forgive me
hold on here
let me uh ali two five i'll come back to
you i'm sorry two five six nine do you
think the dynastic egyptians were
descended from the atlanteans i've
always thought that as an interesting
theory yes they said they were in the
temple of edfu uh
the
uh or hold on just so i just missed
somebody so i got just in time
that's what they say there's two
different sources whether it's plato
saying that they're colonists of
atlantis and oh no did someone just miss
somebody's damn it i'm so sorry guys
he's the five dollar all right so
apparently the more money you give the
longer it stays up i need to start
reading the lower dollar amount ones
first
god damn it i'm missing someone else's
what's in the cup
it's apple juice
um
all right
god all right hold on i think there's a
way i can scroll up and see it again to
answer your question yes the egyptians
say that they're colonizers of atlantis
that the descendants of the primeval
ones
had went over to egypt and recolonized
different parts of the world this is
going to tie into announce one of my
best videos i'll ever make it's a big
one it's a good one
it's gonna tie in the sumerians the
egyptians and the atlanteans and others
and if you compare some stuff that i
hadn't seen before some
historical texts
it seems like that's the answer that's
what i think that's what i do think
disgruntled doomer you run an
interesting channel keep it up thank you
all right so i'm trying to scroll up now
to see the ones i missed
rick johnson thoughts on the monoliths
found on the moons and planets okay so
that's something interesting that uh
buzz aldrin had said that the uh what's
that name of one of mars's moons um it
doesn't matter it has this weird looking
obelisk that's like 300 feet and
standing straight up he says it's there
he went on tv and said this
um he asked people should be asking
questions he said people should be
asking questions about it i think that's
weird so the answer question i don't
know but it all ties in one of my
suspicions of the moon and other things
that there's something there um let me
i'm still scrolling up to see who else
has i missed
forgive
me um
all right hold on i think i'm caught up
now that i see here we got
art of delphi
great work jimmy what are your thoughts
on inner earth argotha
do you feel like some ufos may be coming
from inside the earth okay so let's be
real
first of all i think it's entirely
possible as wild in science fiction as
that may sound to some people
if you look at this uf ufo phenomena
that's happening where they're releasing
videos of these things that are being
observed under the ocean traveling at
hundreds of knots and being tracked by
you know submarine sonar and other
things
if those things are true
then and regardless of their aliens or
not
well i mean
what could they be could they be us but
where did that technology come from
right
and they they're being observed under
the ocean then yeah that might be the
axis you go through caves and on the
because under the ocean whether it's the
mid-atlantic ridge and other places this
i don't know most people might not
understand just how huge of an area this
is and how very possible it would be
that if there was a cave system there if
you wanted to hide anything on earth it
would be through under the ocean
so yeah man i'm open to it but i just
don't know i don't know
hold on one second i mean all right so
hold on let me just say that's gonna
have to time to be that's gonna have to
be a video at some point because i have
my i'm gonna have to
make a video on the ufo phenomena i said
i would do it a while back and i haven't
gotten into it and there's so much to
say because i kept waiting i'm like
there's got to be more information
that's coming light because it kept
accelerating so
you know i'm going to just hold that
thought and go into a whole video on it
latar
lemphis i don't know
how to pronounce that but there's 1290
check
i don't know how much that equates to
but it's very generous i believe
regardless of the amount i don't know
what i almost want to google it right
now because it's such a big number thank
you you said
um
thanks for dedication and videos regards
that is extremely nice of you
emerson calvallo
or if i said or cavallo cavallau
either way thank you emerson you rock
that was very nice of you to say
and donate you guys are so sweet who
else has a question
i'm learning here
someone said i'm a bit skeptical of
aliens on earth let me just say this i
mean me too i don't know either way
what if
they never left
go look at obama
then president obama when he was on
jimmy kimmel and he was asked by aliens
and he jokingly says he's clearly joking
but the question is if he's if it's true
he said because jimmy kimmel was he
asked multiple presidents about ufos and
area 51 all that and he says that he was
jokingly laughing but he was really
awkward about it and you watch like
these videos on youtube with people like
psychoanalyzing him these truth
detectors
he basically said something to the
effect of that you know
they're controlling all of us and they
won't let us expose their secrets but
he's really awkward about it he's joking
he's laughing by the way so it's like ha
ha funny
and maybe he's just being a troll maybe
or maybe he's literally telling you the
truth and maybe this is why we there's
so much we don't know and maybe the
powers that be know that
there are advanced intelligent aliens or
whatever essentially
hanging around and
what oh my phone's blow hold on my
phone's lighting up
are people vending my uh money
oh my god i think that's what that is i
can't say for sure
because it already went away i don't
want to touch my screen and mess it up
um but it just caught my eye and went
away
first of all whoever just gave me money
on venmo if that's what i saw thank you
and forgive me for plugging it again
but
i think because i have a patreon and if
you want to donate monthly on patreon or
one time thank you very much it's very
nice of you i can use this money for
future travels
another because not everyone's on
patreon
i do have a venmo now because venmo was
so many people around i'm like i should
probably do that so my venmo is bright
underscore insight just like my
instagram if you're not following me on
instagram go follow me there because i'm
trying to grow it and even though i
think
i mean they're related to facebook which
is trash
mark zuckerberg can go to hell um but
i'd love to just delete all social media
but i'm in the game right i got to do it
kind of you kind of have to
so follow me on there because i'm going
to be posting and i do post like when i
travel peru and egypt you know
things every day so you'll just see far
more on there than you'll see anywhere
else and it's a fun way to stay in touch
and you know you can dm me on there
there's so many people i haven't been
able to respond to on dm and forgive me
but the love is there and i'm so
grateful
so yeah if you want to tip me on venmo
and let me use that money for
various endeavors and future travels and
just support or whatever
i'm very grateful
um
saul a
what are the oligarchs hiding in
existence a pre-cataclysmic worldwide
flood well
that's a very good question isn't it and
if all these p powerful people are super
interested in the ancients which they
are many of them uh
i think they know something we don't but
maybe not hey guys it's a big conspiracy
conspiracies exist people conspire every
day to do things on the dl that are
illegal or otherwise immoral and out of
sight from the general public that's a
fact
conspiracy theory was created the word
because it's so negative it is a fact
that cia did create that term
during when the a couple years after the
jfk assassination when the theory
started really developing that word was
created in direct response to that
conspiracy theory that term was created
because of that
because it's condescending it works it's
very effective actually
are you a conspiracy theorist
and people like well no
right no one wants to be labeled
okay uh brendan does things what type of
phone will you use to record with you on
your trip okay so i have iphone 12 pro
it's very good
um however and i'm going to use that but
this time i will be using
a selfie stick which will be far better
however my best videos that i'll i'll be
using that to do instagram stuff so
follow me on instagram so you'll be able
to see these things
um however for actual quality videos
for future videos uh like youtube videos
excuse me i'm gonna be using this bad
boy so i shared this earlier in the in
the live stream but there's new people
on here by the way there's a thousand
people out here you guys are awesome
um this is a dgi osmo 2 this thing is
badass it is a 4k 60 frames per second
wide angle and it is unbelievably good
quality you can do pictures and video
it's got a joystick this thing it it
will follow your face it will also um
what i'm thinking of reduced um
shake what do you call there's a
terminology for it anyways so you're
carrying it around and it oh
stabilization excuse me
this thing is badass i'll be using this
and it also has a wireless bluetooth
microphone of high quality hells yeah
then i have
my
mirrorless
hd camera which i brought uh
to egypt last time but this time i'm
gonna have a polarizing lens which will
be better uh uh as well as this big
light which i was sharing earlier hold
on here
and it it has multiple shades of color
you can do you know
see that
this thing is far brighter than you see
this thing is gonna this lens already
picks up on low light
sensitivity quite well
this
is gonna make a phenomenal difference
particularly when i'm in the serpent
with those 100 ton stone boxes
um
so let's see here
vector force thank you again have you
heard of the emerald tablets of those
and the atlanteans absolutely um
okay i just need to make a video on that
um
there's some interesting things about
the emerald tablets because isn't it
still a mystery where they came from and
wasn't it isaac newton that had
deciphered them
um i i find as above so below to be
extremely interesting which to me almost
gives it some credibility i feel like it
could be evidence of ancient knowledge
and wisdom that was passed down
and they're trying to share it so
i don't necessarily remember the aliens
being included i've read that before but
i feel like when i had read about it i
don't know where i saw that that was
included forgive me i'm on the spot
right now i haven't looked into it in a
while um let me scroll down because i
just missed i think another person's
super chat
let me see if i can scroll up
yeah rick johnson can you see the
ancient copper wiring in the pyramids
i didn't
but
i can
show
you
i mean let me just say something that
comes to mind about that
is the various rust marks around the
giza plateau that maybe there was some
ancient
metal there but it could just be iron
deposits
but one thing that comes to mind which
is unrelated but interesting nonetheless
that i'll share based on your question
which is that one thing i didn't know
existed around the giza plateau which
i'll also be showing you when i do my
live stream so real quick to anyone
that's new to this let me just point out
before i get back on that
that next friday october 1st i will be
doing a live stream across the giza
plateau it's gonna be awesome it's gonna
be epic and i'm gonna show you all the
things you didn't know existed one of
which which comes to mind based on your
question uh rick is that there's like
this whole system
of pipes around stone pipes made out of
quartzite by the way
and quartz along the giza plateau they
were they were funneling water all over
the place
for what
it's supposed to just the academics it's
just you know it's just a tomb it's a
cemetery nothing to see here they were
moving water all over the place and they
chose quartz of all things for some
reason it's extremely interesting
but as far as copper wiring in the
pyramids let me dig into that
let me look at
is it reisel
r-s-y-l-e
buy a water a bot a water bottle for
yourself for me you're sweet i will
or i'll buy beer with it
um
let's see here
la taro lin fist again 249
check thank you before biden 1290 was
less generous now looks better
dm instagram visit bolivia next time you
go to peru many interesting places free
translator and place to stay you are a
gentleman and let me just say we were
supposed to go to bolivia when i was in
peru last month but the borders were
closed to get in it was going to take
hours
and you had to go this whole process and
everyone would have had to do it and
there's 35 of us on the tour and then we
had to get retested again we'd have to
do an additional covet test it was
completely not feasible
but i am very optimistic the next time i
go down there
those
issues will have been resolved or at
least i want to believe
um hold on i'm getting a little bit of a
dry mouth here guys because i'm talking
my head off
are you guys enjoying this live stream
i hope so i'm having fun um give me a
thumbs up if you haven't already we've
got more than a thousand people in here
i'm very generous it shows that i
started how many minutes ago let me
refresh this forgive me
107 minutes ago
all right oh chat's going you guys are
nice is that apple juice that is what it
is it's apple juice
keeping up on my vitamins if you believe
me
it is whiskey
um
al or af easy got another one here did
you know when isis wasn't committing
atrocities they would diligently go
around and destroy ancient sumerian
temples and artifacts why
you guys really want to know what i
think
so first of all
isn't it interesting that they randomly
decided to do that
they were using
like new well i don't want to say new
let me back up they were using
exceptional heavy lifting
equipment you know john deere stuff like
dozers and everything else to destroy
all those sites
i'm
i'm just going to share
what i heard him say with my own eyes
and ears that the mainstream media in
the u.s has never reported on
and is extremely interesting
because
before i say that let me tell you why i
believe him because it already confirmed
what i already thought which is that
back in like 2012
i want to believe or 2013 one or the
other
when isis was storming iraq
when they were going over the sinjar
mountains which is exactly where i was
at i was in tel afar iraq and then mosul
tel far iraq has the sinjar mountains
which is incredibly special in that the
yazidis which are the people that were
completely decimated when isis stormed
that was where isis came over and
invaded iraq iraq
and the sinjar mountains is where they
say that the devil had landed
the exact spot
how freaking
eerie is that they said when the devil
came to earth he landed on the top of
that mountain
anyway
i remember in my
some of my army friends felt at that
time that there was something incredibly
interesting about the timing of that
invasion hey thank you jonathan for the
50 bucks and the super sticker what a
nice generous
gift what a
you guys are awesome
we remember thinking there was something
really weird about it i'm like why are
they doing this now what's the story
here i'm like i'm like who's funding
these people
like they had vehicles and guns and
there's these random people i'm like
in everything i know i'm like these
people look like the examples of
sociopaths like they were complete
conquerors and like there seemed to be
no
they just seemed to be more to the story
is what my vibe on it was and then later
on i saw a video clip of vladimir putin
from russia let me just say i don't
expect you guys to believe me or him i'm
not saying he's right or wrong i'm just
gonna tell you what he said go youtube
it you can watch it with your own eyes
and ears okay what he had said was that
i mean he the way he said let me just
say i
i believed him
he looked like at this reporter like
they're the dumbest people on earth and
he's like are you guys ever going to
report on what i'm telling you he's like
they're mercenaries
he said that isis were mercenaries which
means that somebody's paying them to go
do that
and i'm like why are they like messing
with this
uh gate of nergal and in these these
these statues and tearing all this down
like why like
wildly bothering
i just felt
and the way it was reported too i'm like
you had the media there ready to go and
isis is destroying these sites the exact
site that i was at
right there where i had stood
i just thought that was weird now i
don't know who's paying it well
i have an idea and i'm not going to say
that right now i'll save that so someone
asked me earlier what things i don't
want to talk about i'll leave that i'll
hold off on saying that on the live
stream
but
you know in person i would happily
say what i think is possible but i just
thought that was interesting he said
that he said i i kind of just believed
him i'm like he seemed to just be
sharing it and the fact that the u.s
never even addressed it because he could
just you know try to debunk him whatever
i just thought it was interesting so to
answer your question i feel like maybe
there was some people that had
that that went out of their way to make
sure those sites were destroyed now why
that's a really good question isn't it i
don't know why i don't know who did it i
don't know why but something happened
and these people seem to be funded i'll
say that too it just seemed to make
sense from what i know about just
logistics and i mean even like getting i
mean let's just stole everything right
but i don't know i'll get off that topic
it's a little dark
ancient history experience i'm still
here andrew you need to come to egypt
i'll be thinking about you brother when
i'm in egypt next week i'm gonna make
sure i get sweet because last time i was
there i sent you the sweet photos of the
various nubs around the plateau they
were in some weird spots besides just
the pyramids or the the third period
pyramidari um
anyways
no idols allowed in their religion okay
there you go that could actually make
total sense right yeah just destroy it
it conflicts with your modern religion
and like what the f is this goodbye it
could be that simple no conspiracy you
just want to get rid of it just like
we've seen throughout history whether
it's the spaniards invading peru and
destroying all their crap which i
witnessed
which was unbelievable i didn't realize
it's very comparable to what had
happened involving the
um
the colonizers of the united states
overthrowing and destroying and
conquering the native americans
so
ancient his all right next year maybe we
got to make it happen um
all right we got jordy lancel
it's past 2 am here already in the
netherlands i'm heading out i'll talk to
you in egypt on friday take care of
yourself man jordy i'll remember that
jordy lencel see this is so much fun
because the same thing happened when i
was in egypt last year there's a couple
people dude i was watching your live
stream and i left a super chat i
remember aaron aaron if you've seen this
you're wonderful
um but it's the same thing and all of a
sudden next year or excuse me week i'll
be
at the marriott meena house and someone
named jordy is going to come up to like
hey that was me i'm like that was you
and i'm gonna buy him a beer if he wants
to drink
um
fun stuff
jimmy take me with you i'll be your bar
to god i'm 6'4 cac is his name hell
yeah
i need i think i could throw down a
little bit i'm very but you could always
use some bodyguards right
i'm not i think my best advantage will
be seeing danger right before it happens
it's hard to get the jump on me but hey
you get to jump on anyone right that's a
real thing
um but that's dark we'll go on to the
next thing um
jimmy wish i could go with you
unfortunately we're not we're all locked
down australia oh my god let's not talk
about it you oh my god my poor friends
in australia
i'm seeing what's going on i'm watching
the video if you guys aren't aware of
what's happening in australia and
melbourne and other things you need to
be paying attention now more than ever
i'm thinking about you guys
but let's get off that topic i don't
want to get this into a whole this is
you know because guys i got to you know
choose a hill to die on
and right now it's
well it's not premature now is the time
to speak up but what i'm saying is that
for me
i got to be very careful on the things
i'm choosing to talk about i can't talk
about everything
um
until the timing's just right
and then
who knows but
let's get on jimmy how's your love life
ah who's asking ernest
i've been doing the online dating apps
which are hilarious
um i've met some nice people but who
knows
um is someone here do you use roids just
go to the gym
no i've never used roids i'm not that
big i mean i'm vascular but i've always
been vascular but i do go to the gym i
was there this morning begin back into
it
and um it's very nice you just say
that's a compliment asking my better
voice no roads would break me down
my god no one should use that stuff that
stuff catches up with you you know like
injuries later in life and other things
um
let's see here jimmy is a daddy no i'm
not i don't have any kids yeah yeah i'm
a dad i got sawyer come here sawyer
let's see let's see let's uh hold on one
second guys
hi sawyer
what's going on
look at him
you having a good time
good boy good boy
it's me and the dog here it's a total
bachelor pad guys it's me and the dog
good boy sawyer let's see what else we
got here
does anyone have any oh oh hold on am i
missing someone's uh okay rick johnson
our government has many secrets that we
will never know correct
rick johnson is correct
um let's see here what else we got
it's okay sawyer
jeffrey ball
there's a lot of things happening
jeffrey
um there's a lot of things everyone
needs to be paying attention but guys
let's keep the conversation light
that here's what's fun about the ancient
topic there's a chance to escape from
some of the things that are going on the
world that are beyond our control or
that bring us immense suffering just
thinking about
and um
all right so someone wrote what is your
travel itinerary ccr tv i read it off uh
probably a half hour ago or so but if
you want to see go to
chematology
k-h-e-m-i-t-o-l-g-y did i say that right
chematology chematology.com chematology
uh or go to google
chemist school of ancient misses
mysticism and then if on the front page
or if you click under travel or tours
you will see our entire itinerary day by
day it's all on there
or when i'm done with this live stream
this will be posted and you can go back
and watch and i'll list it all off but
we're going to all kinds of sites
okay
um who else some stuff
let's see timothy you're a dog person
too i am a dog person i didn't see what
you wrote before that but um
let's see
do i believe all right uh catman do you
believe in the spiritual realm yes
i've dabbled in it it is a real thing
i'm absolutely 100 convinced
it is provable i've witnessed miracles
and
i don't but no one can possibly leave
until they see them believe themselves
and the power is in with all of us and
it involves belief
this is some people will think i'm
totally whack whack woo-woo right now i
don't care you don't have to believe me
um
it's fine i'll just share what i what i
i'll just share um and it's harmless
regardless even if i'm wrong it's a path
to a better healthier life anyway
i used to so i was raised catholic and i
smelt the early on with that
and refused to get confirmed
and all that and um
hold on someone asked what miracle well
maybe i'll well okay let's see here um
and i used to think that in what was
interpreted as like making everyone
believe you're supposed to believe
you're supposed to believe and i
remember thinking that that was
manipulating people to be like believe
and donate in the collection
you know box or bin or bull
or else
that's what i used to think and now i
believe that it's been completely
misinterpreted all the way around which
is that
if you look at some of the most
successful people on earth they talk
about the power of belief they talk
about manifestation and law of
attraction now let me be clear
sitting around and wishing for things
and thinking about it all day ain't
gonna do for you
however the power of visualization
and taking actionable uh steps in the
direction of a goal
and putting the physical end behind it
which is hard work
but if you visualize you have
you already have it is before
you have it so you visualize
what it's like to have already achieved
the goal
that is the secret
it's not about
picturing you you're gonna get it no all
you're ever gonna have is the want it's
not about wanting something this is i'm
convinced all right let me put it this
way if you really want to know my my
thoughts
neville goddard godard wherever you say
it neville n-e-v-i-l-l-e
goddard
g-o-d-d-a-r-d you can watch his lectures
on youtube he passed away in the 70s the
late neville
confirmed i didn't come across him until
what i believe through my all my
experimentation into this topic
um
oh jonathan is that a no thank you oh
that's the same one confirm what i had
figured out on my own which was when i
was all right so i got divorced i'm
living in boise idaho i'm living with
the dogs at the time
and i'm just experimenting with this
stuff and i never been so alone lonely
and i i was really dabbling into the law
of attraction and experimenting and
there were certain things that worked in
certain things that didn't and it took
years to figure some of these things out
what he ended up saying confirmed what i
believe
which is that the the bible for example
has been completely misinterpreted in
that it should be re-read in first term
the best way to possibly understand it
would have been to write it out as if
you wrote it and that many of the things
that jesus or who else or otherwise had
said was meant to be read as if you
wrote it yourself
neville goddard
explains these things in a way that to
me i'm like confirmed what i already
believe i had figured out
it is exhausting to do these things it
takes a lot of concentration and we are
so distracted with so many things in our
life
and
um
but you'll never be able to do it if you
don't believe it's all about belief
belief belief belief believe you've
already done it guys my entire channel
is an example of the law of attraction
anyone that's followed me from the
beginning saw how my videos were
i i have something like 90 videos up
right now but i've made more than 200.
those of you that went there from the
beginning didn't see the grind that i
did
it's like the saying like everyone sees
the shine nobody sees the grind or
whatever
i
had to i failed so much it took me four
months to get a hundred subscribers is
how bad these videos were because now
people say because i've even had some
friends like oh yeah you're just good at
it like no
no you didn't do you see like the dozens
and dozens of videos i made that were
complete garbage
um and i was so awkward and i'm still
trying to get better but i'm like some
people just assume like oh you're just
good at this stuff no i had to literally
adapt and i had to
i believe i manifested this whole
shebang i i set a goal and i'm like i
want to get a million followers it was a
big goal at the time i'm like i believed
i could do it i just didn't know how
long it would take and how much
suffering i was gonna require to get
there
but if you believe that you can do
something
you can do it
and you just got to put the the power of
intention behind it you got to make up
your mind i'm going to do it and you got
to visualize what will be like already
having been done and in the process your
mind will flourish with creativity
that's part of the secret too is that if
you really want to access the creative
realm it involves the power of belief as
well because then there's ideas that
i'll if i believe i'm going to create a
fantastic video and i've done this many
many times guys i'm not bragging i'm
telling you what i did i wanted to get
millions of views and then i went on the
streak of getting like 11 this little
bit ago but i remember going in the
streak of 11 videos in a row where i got
more than a million views that's a hard
thing to do
and i was doing it all the time but
practicing this stuff in my mind which
is always visualizing my art here's the
video topic but what is it going to look
like and then in the process i'd be like
you know walking my dog just being in
nature or whatever and these ideas would
come out of nowhere i'm like that needs
to be in the video
and i was just picturing like i'm
creating a good video and i get another
idea and i'm like where the are
these ideas coming from
that's the moments that i've been the
most creative and that's why i think
these things work and i think this ties
into nikola tesla and i know this is so
woo-woo for some people guys even if
it's not we were the spiritual realm it
doesn't matter maybe this is just the
way that the mind can become more
creative without any woo-woo all i know
is that it works just believing that you
can do something good or
impressive
will lead your brain to
open up with more ideas if nothing else
at all maybe that's just how it works i
don't know all i know is that it works
and the power belief is the key hold on
let me read some let me oh let me read
some of these all right hold on i'm
sorry moses hey jimmy do you know
there is a second older pyramid inside
the cow uh uh
calculus pyramid at chichen itza and the
footage is incredible highly recommend
gonna go there and see it for myself
brother
and i will put it on the internet
are you gonna make more videos on
atlantis and its relationship to other
civilization yes one of my biggest
videos that has yet to come is on that
exact topic
and is going to come after egypt 100
i'm convinced that it might be one of my
best videos yet
but we'll see
hey i'll use the power of manifestation
and law of attraction to do it um rick
johnson have you heard of people that
could mentally project themselves into
other planets it was a government
project i have heard of that as a real
experimentation they did like such as
mars and um what they call it astral
projection right or something to that
effect
i don't know if it's true or not
but i know for sure that they spent
decades investigating that which is
super interesting you think they would
have given up after a few months or a
year or whatever and they've spent years
on that stuff guys
um i'd be so curious i didn't see any
comments on all this stuff i was saying
for the last couple of minutes while i
was on my little soapbox some wrote
ernest sorry preach jimmy yes i'm i'm
scrolling up now i want to see what you
guys were saying about this because i've
heard other people whether it's like
and and some of you will like think
these are crazy examples but whether
it's like conor mcgregor and that's a
ufc fighter so you could say like that
has nothing to do with what i'm doing
but like many many people
and i can name other names but some
people will uh
andrew ancient christians criticisms i
get your method many other people like
it doesn't matter what industry or realm
you're in i'm like guys there's
something to the power belief so even if
you don't think it's the physical realm
and and by the way that just reminded me
of what i was going to say a moment ago
about nikola tesla
saying his quote about the mind being
the part of the wheel work of the
universe if you look at nikola tesla and
einstein so i need to make a video on
this again because some of my real
videos were on nikola tessa and those
things helped me like get my channel
going my first million plus video ever
was on nikola tesla
if you look at the works of einstein he
was talking about how all of his ideas
came through imagination and how
nikola tessa his all the improvements he
made to his inventions came from him
brainstorming
like
guys it's it's ideas that come to you
and it's like where are these ideas
coming from are like are our brains like
this wi-fi receptor
of some kind because sometimes guys some
of my best ideas for my most successful
videos i've ever made came out of
absolutely nowhere and all i'm wondering
is where the idea came from
is it a is it a muse of some kind it
doesn't have to be beings beyond us
could it be energies could it be give me
anything i don't know
all i know is that these ideas have
worked for me
and i'm convinced and i've seen them
verified by other people that have that
have done them themselves
um
and that includes a lot of people that i
find quite inspiring but i don't want to
just like name drop these famous people
because some of them have a lot of
um cons to them or or attributes that
you might be like well you shouldn't
trust them because of this they've done
this in their life that's not good but
i'm like you can use these things for
good or bad
but you can use them and i'm convinced
that this is the secret knowledge that
it's the it's the reality that we're all
god so to speak that we're all part of
the creator and creator could be
nothing more than the entire universe in
the thought i'm not
referring to an individual
i'm referring to the all and infinite
consciousness and we're all tied to it
because if our bodies are made up of
dozens and dozens of elements which they
are like let me give you an example
we wouldn't live none of us would be
alive if it wasn't for the iron within
our blood you can see there's enough
iron in it that magnets can respond to
it there's been experiments you can
watch it on youtube they took a bunch of
pig's blood which is very similar to
humans by the way
and you could put like
a gallon of it or whatever and you put
like
uh essentially you move magnets and you
put like a cup of it and you move the
magnet around it you can slowly steer
the the blood or the the the cup of it
i'm not explaining it well at all you
just have to see it done but the point
is that without iron in our blood you
wouldn't be alive so
metal you're made of metal well
computers are made of metal too and if
you look at all the other like elements
that are our bodies are made of that we
couldn't exist without it i'm like well
you kind of are the universe because
you're made of it and you won't exist
without these other little elements
i'm going deep aren't i
latar of the fist all right hold on how
much is
1290 czk to us because you've done this
a couple of times already so i have to
guys let's take an opportunity to see
how generous this person is and
i don't care how much it'd be one dollar
i'm so grateful guys i need
i don't maybe i shouldn't put you on the
spot but i'm so freaking curious all
right so czk to us let's use google
that's 59 dollars and 42 cents us you've
already done this like a couple times
that is way too generous that is
extremely nice of you i love you i'm
gonna give you a big kiss
he said just an idea law of attraction
belief whatever we call it it is not
important just realize that everything
is happening right now it is just for
you there is nothing else no one else
just you and now and this moment has
everything and it's just you
brilliant
that is all that exists everyone you are
spot on what a great beautiful way to
put it
the only thing that ever exists or time
is is now the past happened we know that
we have a memory
the future will come
obviously we know tomorrow you know we
can we can
analytically describe it
like oh yeah i'm gonna wake up in the
morning i'll be 8 a.m or whatever but
the only moment that ever truly exists
is right now and it's always right now
right now right now right now right now
right
and when you realize that then you have
power of choice and you always have a
choice this is where the power of
intention comes in which is that i can
choose to instead of right now me
drinking or playing
some game or goofing off or doing
nothing i could choose to be actively
working on something productive or
whatever it is you know helping to
create a turn a dream into a reality i
could do that and that is the power
it's about choice and it's extremely
easy to be distracted with everything
else
um
this is like almost something they don't
want everyone to know and i believe
these are the ancient teachings is that
we are creators far more so than they
want you to believe
you know it's all in us guys the powers
within us
oh diddy here we go
uh water is well our bodies are mostly
water so keep it pure as positive amen
um and it's so true okay hold on here
nick
berling inieri forgive me if i pronounce
that incorrectly are you going are you
getting to these places like egypt
without a vaccine because if you are
tell me your secret respect
yeah respect for you brother i'll hire
to say these cigarettes egypt is not
requiring the vaccine no you just have
to have a negative
code pcr test to get in
that's it
and i have not had the vaccine hey
because people got so mad at me in the
last livestream by what i said it
because i said i'm never getting it and
that's my choice if you want to go get
it go get it
but
i don't need it i've already had a
covet and i'm just that's my own
decision
and respect me don't leave me alone
people are like
toy boxer no i'm not anti-vaxx
screw you i was in the military i got 11
shots in 60 seconds not including that
goddamn peanut butter penicillin shot
they threw in my ass everyone's in the
military you know what that's about my
god i'm not anti-vaccine my kids would
get measle mom's rubella too good for me
good for them
but don't come at me like that people
like you know
don't get me going timothy nathan chug a
beer for me thanks brother um
yeah like this whole thing is they're
turning it guys i know so many people
look at the vex that got covered
afterwards really bad okay like and i
had copied without getting the vax and i
was pretty much okay i think it's my own
body type
my exercise my healthy diet getting a
lot of vitamin d i mean you can't tell
with these white ass arms but i'm in
here i get vitamin d all right i'm just
a pasty dude so like leave me alone like
you know if you want to wear
you know protective measures and not
travel or stay home and order delivery
you go do that but i just don't like how
society is turning into this us versus
them this is extremely dangerous this is
what happened in the soviet union china
with the maoists nazi germany they turn
people against each other stop it
don't get me going do whatever you want
listen to the health officials don't get
me going this covered thing you get me
in trouble just
yeah
history with kaylee jimmy can i have
some good vibes from you today has been
a rough day and i could use some good
vibes and to everyone here call your
loved ones and tell them you love them
while you still can
i don't know what to make of that kaylee
i don't know uh
i am sending you good vibes and i hope
your day wasn't too rough i don't know
what you mean by that um
everyone give history with kaylee some
love she's a sweetheart she has an
awesome channel and she seems i don't
know her all that well but she seems
like a very nice person
and everyone hey everyone type in love
you kaylee into the v into the chat come
on now kaylee with a k she's a very nice
person and now we all could use some
good vibes and
um
because guys we're all in on this
together i mean whether whatever's going
on in our lives we all have something in
common here which is the passion for the
ancients and our inquisitive nature for
finding the truth and my worst fear i
feel is coming to light where people are
are
you know
turning against each other i'm like this
is not good at all not good at all
not good good good historically speaking
um all right let's see here we got
ali 2567 big fan of your insight
humanity's humanity has existed for
hundreds of thousands of years the
notion that civilization civilization
has uh started 6000 years ago was crazy
older civilizations
uh that we don't have archaeological
evidence for is likely 100 agree
100 and here's how you know
the science shows that humans have
existed at least 300 to 350 000 years
ago in our current physical form
involving our cranial size cavity same
size brain skeleton structure at least
300 to 350 000 years ago okay
so
many
cataclysmic events have happened in that
period of time randall carlson has
pointed out in the last 150 or so 144
000 years there's been at least 16
events that were so cataclysmic whether
it's the toba super option of 72 000
years ago or the younger dryas and many
other things
we're so bad that if it happened today
it would be a civilization reset
potentially not an extinction level but
enough to where it's like society would
collapse and it'd be chaos and you'd
have to start over and just a lot of
things would fall apart
and and it would change things up right
and those things have indeed happened
and humans have been around for that
long and combine that with other science
which is that they're saying that if
humans were to
disappear off planet earth today
the last remaining structure on earth
would be the hoover dam that within 10
000 years would the concrete would
curate and fall apart now that's
actually not technically true the great
pyramid giza will still be around
i saw some articles actually so these
are two conflicting articles not related
saying they'll be around for hundreds of
thousands of years uh yeah and actually
realistically more like millions because
it's layer after layer after layer you
know much how much erosion is gonna have
to happen just for one layer to go away
of
external blocks and there's many those
things been around for millions of years
i think so but but everything else will
disappear metal plastic and let me just
say people are like we would find
plastic if the ancients were advanced or
i'm like not necessarily you could
maybe they were smart enough to not use
plastic i've heard graham hamcock say
that
and
you know there's other ways
you know like for example the hemp plant
related to marijuana cannabis um is
completely biodegradable can having
unbelievably strong plastic
and 100 biodegradable there are other
ways of doing things even stainless
steel tooling if you throw it in the
dirt it will rest away it just takes a
little bit longer and as soon as it's
scratched it's screwed
one little chip in it done
and then if you look at old cars world
war ii or whatever in some junk yard
they're resting through straight through
like nothing lasts guys and when we're
talking about
thousands of years or ten thousand years
or tens of thousands of years
nothing's left but stone
all right we got hold on here
is it kyra or kira
kira
fifty dollars how genius jimmy you are
so perfect oh my god you sound sweet hon
let me see here you look pretty maybe hi
kyra
that's a very generous gift i'd be
curious to know what it is i said that
you like i appreciate it
the daydream band you become what you
think about aka daydreaming from the
strangest secret in the world earlying
earl nightingale oh wow
yes
thank you
outstanding thank you for your awesome
content thank you very much you are so
what we focus focus our our thoughts on
we do become even um
one of the caesars said this i don't
know if it was julius or um forgive me
but
this is true actually
so that's one reason how my that helped
my channel too take off when i was
talking about you know the power of you
know manifestation bullets visualization
i was spending all right so here's what
happened i got divorced i'm living alone
with the dogs i had like no hardly any
friends in boise no family and i just
spent all my time thinking about the
ancients now it's more difficult now
because i'm so distracted with other
things in my life but when i spent all
of my time thinking about these topics
it was so easy and then i became the
youtuber i wanted to be i want to be you
know this big youtuber making all these
talking about interesting
theories not just the ancients i talked
about jfk and nikola tesla spiritual
stuff um and other things aunt dowdy
ching you'll remember that um
so
that's the that is the secret you are
what you think about amen
um zero fx gaming tell k we all wish
your good vibes don't let the bastards
drag you down
um
and whether it's that or family stuff or
maybe sick loved ones or whatever it
could be
you know
hell yeah that's all nice of you guys to
do that um
hey will you guys hang on just a half a
second oh wait oh i got water right here
i was gonna pour myself another cocktail
or orange juice or apple juice what did
i say
hold on
wow there's 1100 people in here i feel
so blessed um
well i'll tell you what
you guys hang on so i have a liquor cart
it's awesome it's over there i actually
normally keep it right here but i don't
want it to be in the in the
shot it's a pretty sweet thing i got on
amazon it looks awesome i got a bunch of
bottles on it i'm gonna pour myself a
tiny little cocktail you guys hang with
me i'm gonna put a little ice cube in
here i'm not gonna be far away so if it
looks like i'm gone i'm really not i
don't know if you guys will be able to
hear me but just hang tight i'll be back
in like 30 seconds this is gonna be
quick because it's all right here
hang on
let's see
down here
you guys get on amazon you get these big
blocks
big square block
yeah i'll be right back hang on
okay
i'm gonna tell you guys what i'm having
but you're gonna laugh at me but hang on
a second
okay
hi sawyer
i don't know if you guys could hear that
but here we go
you guys ready to laugh at me so here's
the situation
so this
is not as strong or big as it thinks
well first of all that huge ice cube so
this is literally about one and a half
shots or so
uh ounces let's say um so this is
fireball it
don't laugh at me i actually like it but
i don't do shots of it if you pour it in
with ice and i what i did is i put a
bunch of water so you saw i poured it i
showed you and i went over to my little
water thing and i diluted it with water
to make it a little bit less sweet but
there's something fun about it because
it's not strong it's like 60 something
proof so it's not like full blown
whiskey and i guess with its high
concentration of sugar it's kind of a
fun buzz
you know the sugar with the alcohol so
you can laugh me all you want because
like people laugh like because i have
fireball in the car like you drink this
i'm like
no yeah
not shots of it
um what did people say go like yeah
water right i swear to god you saw it i
poured it i went over there like come on
now um but let's see here let me get
back to these super chats what are your
thoughts about the sumerians and the
annunaki and human origins love your
content and insight okay
without talking about zechariah sitchin
because he may have not been right or
maybe he was exaggerating or whatever it
doesn't mean that he's wrong but i'm not
quoting him here
i'm very interested i do look at those
tablets and i do think that they
understood
the solar system
it's there it's the sun and implants
around it that's what i think other
people experts academics whoever they
disagree they say no it's not fine they
can think what they want i think that
there is and i think they had advanced
knowledge there's also a tablet that
shows them like looking up at this like
a person on like this thing with wings
i think they're literally trying to show
you that someone came here guys
that's what i that's what i think i
think it's extremely likely but maybe
not it could not if nothing else it's a
fun topic but dustin harry
what do i think i think there's
something to it um
so let's see here rick johnson
interested on your thoughts on the ark
it seems they found remnants dude i
don't even know what to think because i
don't know what the arc is was it
knowledge was it the ten commandments
was it the was it
was okay put this way
if there was an ancient technology is
that it because if you look at
um
a lot of the glyphs in egypt
they all have this thing they call it
the um
was it the jed the uh supposed to be
osiris's backbone it just doesn't look
anything like a backbone
to me it seems to me because they show
up like handing off to people i'm
thinking
that's the technology it looks like
something was made to operate with
frequency
and you've never found anything like it
so i'm like what the hell is this thing
so
um
the ark might be exactly what that is i
just don't know and maybe it was stored
in the great pyramid i don't know i'm
really open-minded
but man that gets me thinking
this is something i'm gonna have to
cover when i go back to egypt here all
right thomas o'brien jimmy you are so
knowledgeable and passionate about so
many topics i've followed your channel
for a while where do you do your
research i want to know what you know
can you refer sites videos books people
please never stop doing what you're
doing that is a very sweet comment
thomas that means a lot to me
okay so i'll tell you exactly what i do
and it's not hard anyone can do what i
do
i do a couple things
there's any topic in itself let's just
say it's the great pyramid
i read what all the academics say about
it this is what's taught
here's what they all say and here's all
their explanations cool
then i'll look at a number of
alternative researchers on what they
have to say whoever i think's the most
credible
those people you know people that you
know level-headed people whether it's
graham hancock and whether it's randall
carlson or there's so many others i mean
where do i begin i don't want to start
naming names and forget somebody
um
and then
i will look at maybe more of the crazy
theories or some of the other like
there's so many when i say alternative
theories it's all over the place because
you get somebody that's saying the
pyramid was a tomb you could have
someone over here saying the pyramid was
a power plant you have someone over here
saying that the pyramid was a uh uh you
know a device for you know tell you know
communication other planets there's so
many different things and i'll look at
all the above and then i just think for
myself and develop my own theories and
there's nothing more powerful than
thinking for yourself you can't be right
about everything but um
that's essentially what i do so as far
as recommending books i well
there's been a many many different
things that i've read but i think that
the where i would
because i feel like i got to give credit
where it's due and people inspired me
most so i would recommend everyone buys
graham hancock's books
um magician of the gods fingerprints of
the gods support him american before i
haven't actually read that yet but i
bought it um
and support him like this guy has
endured so much backlash and uh he's a
smart man and he's sharing things
because he he says it himself he's a
journalist he's a synthesizer people are
going to agree with him it's like most
of the stuff he's citing is things that
other research has already done
and they come after him like he's
putting things together and sharing it
and
and he's right he knows that there's
more there's a mystery to our ancient
past and that's a fact
so um but yeah i'll never stop doing
what i'm doing this is just the
beginning i've said it before but now
it's time like i said earlier in this
conversation this is the time where i
need to get my momentum going
i need to come back from egypt and get
underway back in my grind like i haven't
in a couple years now and just become
obsessed
it's not easy to do though especially
when you have distractions in your life
um but they're all good distractions but
um yeah that's what i need to do because
when i'm when i'm super focused on
something and obsessed that's when i do
my best stuff it's not easy though but
that's what i need to do and comments
like this inspire me guys so just all
send me your best
love and and your support and you guys
all are supportive
but you know sometimes we all need a
kick in the butt right
and that's one thing you know coming
back from peru and then going back to
egypt i feel like reinvigorated
to uh get underway with this stuff um
how long have i been going now
and then an hour 45 minutes that's
pretty cool um or is it 145 minutes it's
hard to say
um
okay so who else has a question or
comment
andrew yes you get burnout yeah all
right so to be honest yeah i did get
burnt out i did and and
that's okay but now i'm feeling like now
it's
it's like a cycle now i feel like i want
to get burnt out again and i feel like
it could take a while before that
happens again because i'm so rested so
to speak
write a book yeah man that's on my list
for sure
jimmy potus 2024 no they would kill me
they would absolutely execute me if i
was potus
they would
it would happen quick too i just
wouldn't i would just talk too much i'd
be doing uh
i'd be doing the whole uh white house or
the oval office speech it'd be similar
to eisenhower's
go look at eisenhower's last speech
before they left the white house he left
the white house before jfk became
president
look what he said about secret societies
and the infrastructure of the
military-industrial complex intelligence
agencies tell you everything you need to
hear
jfk came in and then within 11 months
before his
murder uh look at what he said
exposing secret society seek your size
who be anything could be this
or whatever else like it's you know a
conglomerate of whatever powerful
entities operate with whatever abilities
and and infrastructure and and
influencing society with whatever means
whatever it is that they have that's a
real thing
it's true no it doesn't have to be a big
bearing conspiracy i think it is but i
mean it doesn't have to be
let's see here
colton broccoli that's a fun name uh
taking a road trip soon and would love
to buy you a meal or coffee hell yeah
um buy me steak and beer i'm just
kidding uh that would that would be
lovely hit me up on instagram um that's
nothing and i don't want to plug it
again because i sound like a douche
because i seriously don't like it social
media but i gotta do it if you're not
following me on instagram go follow me
it's bright underscore insight i share
them far more than i do on anywhere else
you know youtube or otherwise
and you know it's a way of keeping up
and getting to know me more and i'll be
sharing things daily uh vlogs and
pictures from egypt i was doing the same
thing in peru and when i went to egypt
last year so um but that's an easiest
way to get in contact with me it's just
that like every time i make a post
people i get dozens sometimes i get 100
dms and i can't
it's it's honestly overwhelming
especially someone like me that doesn't
like to be on my phone that much
it's kind of it sucks because there's a
lot of people i haven't responded to or
i never even saw it by the way i've had
people send me multiple you know
messages i ain't finally seen one i'm
thinking like they sent me a message a
year ago i had no idea
so forgive me if you know someone that
if you've messaged me i never saw it you
know
it's
i guess it's a good problem to have but
i still feel bad because if someone
sends me that love i won't i want to see
it
all right so jake bree uh behrend i
don't know if i said that right but jake
jimmy i think the work you do on your
channel is more important than you
possibly even realize thank you for
everything you do man that's
it's surreal to get a comment like that
all right
see it's stuff like this it's very
motivating guys it makes me want to get
off this live chat and freaking hammer
out my next video
man
um
pools jet
while in the us air force i lived in
turkey and greece for three years each
crazy history for both islamic nations
are a major deal trying to have a peak c
march on sir thank you sir and thank you
for your service you know so funny i
never anytime someone thanks me for my
service here's the best response i got
this from an old friend it was in the
military too so i'd say oh thank you for
your service say thank you for your tax
dollars college intuition and i
when i was in iraq we had that kbr food
and it was steak and lobster tail every
sunday
um
let's see here
huff four three two
what is this
atlantis together
oh atlantis haven't you hit me up before
i feel like we've never been in uh never
chatted though
i recognize it because you're picture is
the the uh it's of the wrist shot the
wrist shot structure what do you guys
think about that huh
okay so what else we got here
i'm looking trying to see through these
comments i'm filter i'm scrolling up
right now here hopefully i don't miss
anything great um
someone said bd or bmd jimmy what do you
think of the whole ce5 thing remote
viewing okay here's the deal
i think all right i think most people
with that are full of however
i don't know what you mean by ce5 if
you're referring to the classified when
they were doing this decades ago and
doing experiments on it they did see
that there was some stuff there so maybe
it i'm not saying it's not possible i'm
not saying it hasn't been done and can't
be done in the future
i think some people are full of it but
to be honest with you i don't know but
this way i haven't done it
but i have had other intuitive moments
in my life i've had in more than one
occasion i've seen things before they
happen kind of like i'm not saying like
total jedi i'm not saying like i like
i'm not talking psychic stuff i'm just
saying i've had weird intuitive moments
that turn out to be correct
just a little bit before and i'm not how
do i explain let me give you an example
um
i'm trying to think of something good
because if i don't give a good example
and it sounds like not good enough at
all um and i'm on the spot right now
um i don't know
for me what i'm most talented at is kind
of sensing what someone's gonna do
like protect like as far as
self-protection
um you know not getting crossed by
people sometimes i've been good at that
intuitively sensing
their underlying motives
um rick johnson the russians beat us to
venus with amazing visuals yeah man they
sent that probe there it only lasted a
few minutes right they got those
pictures why
that's another thing why like venus is
unbelievably interesting it's the
closest planet to us and nobody's
talking about it
everything's mars mars mars what about
venus
what about that you know
um let's see here
someone wrote all right let's see iron y
iron wind 19 17 72. i know what you mean
i sat at an intersection to eat my lunch
and i knew there was going to be a wreck
there a few minutes later a wreck
happened right in front of me yeah man
like weird stuff like that
i've ex so i have a uh my dog sawyer is
dog aggressive it's unfortunate he used
to be really cool but he got bit and
he's ptsd and it's been tough
and i've experimented so i try to avoid
passing other dogs because he lunges a
bit and if he's too close it's so
obnoxious because he's a 100 pound boy
he's got that four wheel drive he's very
very strong and so like i've kind of
experimented with this on dog walks to
try to avoid other people
and i've had some weird results
sometimes but i mean so you can't talk
to people about this you sound crazy or
like oh you're just you know it's
coincidence or you're dumb you know what
you're talking about
i think this comes into power belief i
believe i can be intuitive i believe
you know that can be connected the
source of all that is
and with that can come things that
people would otherwise think aren't
possible that's how i would put it
do you know of dr steven greer
absolutely i think he's done a great
service by
bringing things to light
because what was that documentary was it
um disclosure
i believe where basically if he didn't
if he
i'm not saying he
proved that aliens exist or have visited
earth if he's done nothing else it's
proving that there is a cover-up that
there has been at some level
a
stripping away of information that's
been available to the public
he has proven that so there's something
there there now if it's not aliens if
it's just advanced technological um you
know
uh
classified stuff i mean whatever hold on
i'm distracted hey
over here is my living room window and i
live in this unique setup where like
directly across the street from me or my
neighbors
and now that it's the sun's starting to
go down and i got my lights on in here i
had this feeling of being watched i
can't see
but maybe this is an intuitive moment
all i want to do is shut my blinds real
quick because right now i'm in my
kitchen doing this live stream and i can
just see this couple watching me
probably you know they're like what the
is this guy doing like who's he
talking to
um so this will only take 10 seconds
hold on
so that
that reminds me guys listen to this so
speaking of intuitive moments let me
give you another example and this is so
freaking wild to me that it like
verifies it so when i was living in
boise idaho
when i was making all these videos i was
work i had a desk in the front living
room that that overlooked the street
and
so i would see everything going on in
the neighborhood throughout the day
people walking by with their dogs and
whatever
and you know how you there's a saying
that um
you know people can sense
that someone's watching
them it's true
because i i experience you guys i think
i'm so weird i don't care if you gotta
do the experiment jimmy's gotta know
what's going on i used to try it i used
to just watch the person now let me just
say the way my yard was laid out it
wasn't obvious the window was way back
so we're talking like i don't even know
50 feet from the street not close like
some houses um
and there's a tree in the way and just
the lighting itself you couldn't see in
so even i'd have to have all the lights
on which i normally wouldn't actually
especially during the day because they
got good lighting in but like you
couldn't see from this the reflection
because you know go outside and see them
like so i knew that when i was inside
people wouldn't see me you know i'm
talking about just the reflection of the
glass itself and just the fact that it
faced the uh the north and like knowing
the sun isn't shining in et cetera
so i used to like sometimes just like
stare at the person and i can't believe
how many times all sudden you see
someone you know they'll just be walking
on something you know like like
instinctively look it's a real thing
and let me tell you another thing this
is a random but it's along the same
lines
there was that uh documentary on netflix
i saw a while back about uh i don't
remember the name of it but it may was
the unabomber about uh ted kaczynski the
unabomber
and there was something that happened
that confirms this in my opinion
which is that
he was when he was living in that cabin
out there in the middle of nowhere in
montana he had his near neighbors
whoever it was and there's this woman
and her daughter out walking or doing
whatever they were doing one day and he
was out there with his gun
and he was essentially laying down the
forest and he basically just he was
pissed at these people for some reason i
think it's because they were cutting
trees down and he was really against it
and regardless he pointed it and they
had no idea but he basically and the
reason why they know this is because
when they found his diaries and
everything and he decoded it he wrote in
detail about it on the day he's like i
you know i pointed i had my site by
rifle site right on there
and
these poor people this daughter and this
mom didn't know until many years later
they had this moment when they were out
there that same exact moment
they got this terrible feeling they were
being watched and went and left and went
the other direction which was confirmed
in his writings
what the
what are the odds of that
you have this feeling you're being
watched and you're right and that and
i'm convinced that the conviction and
the
energy he's putting behind it and that
he's pointing a gun at some people some
in a woman and a daughter what's going
what are you doing
um
and so the energy he had behind it was
extremely powerful especially being
someone of such high iq like him he was
a he was a genius just be real
um and use it for doing some terrible
things um
but
yeah like that was guys that happened go
go look into that that's a real thing
and and to me i already saw in my own
eyes i'm like i feel like if you stare
and somebody says they just know
and it's just like what happened with
these blinds i'm like am i being watched
i don't know it's fun stuff i haven't
looked at any of these super chats in a
bit curious we got that we got that does
anyone else have any questions or
comments i mean i'm having a fun time
but i can't tell how much battery life i
have on my phone because the way that
the layout is it doesn't it's just not
showing up so i have no idea let me hold
on give me a half a second here
let me see if that works no that didn't
work at all
dang okay so i have no idea so if this
randomly dies and i don't think it will
because i had a full charge when i
started and it's an iphone 12 and
it could probably probably go
a number of hours i imagine i'm not sure
but i'm having fun i'm in no rush
um
oh my god this had come did you get an
egyptian poon no i did not
you guys some of these comments are so
funny
uh egyptians are incredibly reserved by
the way
um and and religious and conservative um
it's not like american culture i'm going
you know but um
um let's see here who else has a
question i'm trying to scroll through
and see there's so many here and they
just keep going so i don't want to miss
something great um
and i also have a super chat question of
some kind but
all right let's see i'm just looking for
any question i want you guys to feel you
have to pay money to ask me a question
i'll answer anything
bosnian bosnian pyramids i see that from
freaky
no i don't think so man i looked into
this so hold on hold on i'm not saying
it's not something ancient and that
there's not something there
all i'm saying is that i don't
necessarily think it's a pyramid and let
me just say i have not been there but
other people that have been there and
evaluated the site like like say for
example grant hamcock
didn't believe that that's what it was
and i i value that opinion
but i don't know
but if if it is indeed true like with
that example of that leaf that was found
under that um
uh
stone that that that cut stone if that
is indeed 30 000 years old if that's all
true then there's some then there's
something that needs to be discussed so
calling it bosnian pyramids i mean i
mean it looks like it the mountain
itself looks like a pyramid but that
doesn't necessarily mean that's what it
is
i don't know though i just don't know
let me
i'm talking so much i'm freaking
dehydrating here plus my whiskey will
take it out of me
someone asked me jimmy have you read
about the monoliths in russia and canada
what do you think of them okay
i remember looking into that a couple
years ago so it's been a while
and my impression
was that if i remember right i remember
the place where i didn't go down that
path again so i want to say i wasn't
convinced and was waiting to say well
let's wait for more information to come
to light the internet it's 20 you know
whatever year i was looking at this you
know like it's you can't keep things
under wraps very long in these days
so i don't remember thinking that it was
something to it
but who knows i'll i'll i'll bite my
tongue on that because i don't know for
sure all right i don't wanna dude you
keep giving la lotta len fist i don't
even know how to say this the gentleman
who's been very
uh generous to me from the check uh from
uh you know
let's see here
tried to send super chat and after try
sent it showed me edit and try again
well i'm seeing this one
um
what do you want to ask me man
all right so atlantis together what what
is huf hold on here
what currency is that this is so much
fun let's do it right on the fly huf
current oh hungarian of course
um
have you seen the 3d models we created
about the fortresses and the rishot
structure atlantis together.com could
you check
uh the project you inspired i will i
have not seen i will look into it
however if you're referring to
there were
that i had covered in my first videos on
that topic
there were things that looked like
fortresses
but no i have not
i don't know what they are and the last
i heard is that maybe
excuse me um is that they were
uh fencing for cattle or whatever else i
don't know if that's true i don't know
what they were all i know is that i'm
not
aware of the structures actually being
there now but this is something i have
to look into and especially before i
make that next video on the reshot
structure because there will be another
you'd be damn right sure of that so i
gotta look at you dude i haven't i
haven't explored all your stuff i have
been all over the place with so many
things and there's just so many
various topics i need to catch up on but
um let me go to
whatever you're doing keep doing it like
if i can bring a bunch of attention
because i wasn't that big before those
atlantis videos i had three four hundred
thousand subscribers before my first one
and those ones really kind of put me
exponentially it doubled my channel to
be honest
so it's like if you have something put
it out there one video can change your
entire
everything
but dustin harry jimmy have you come
across anything about argartha
underground city somewhere in the asian
mountains curiosity is my sin and
welcome to az thanks man
um yeah i've heard weird things but like
this is like not me when i say her weird
things i hear from somebody i meant like
just you know you see things on the
internet bouncing around and you keep
seeing stuff like that so
i don't know
i don't know what to think i mean i've
heard of like tunnels in afghanistan
i've heard some weird stuff about that
let me type in
our gotha just to double check if it's
the same region i'm thinking of
because of course heard of this a bunch
of times
okay
the legendary kingdom that is said to be
located in the earth's core of course
but where's the entrance to it
um
i would say under the ocean if that
existed because it it brings me back to
as above so below you know
maybe there's something going on inside
the earth i mean like it's so big and it
doesn't have to be a civilization but
like i won't be surprised if there's
some sort of
species of whatever it could be living
under there whether it's insects or
whatever else somewhere he keck he's
drinking fireball yes i'm drinking
fireball with water and ice
[Music]
i like it
i should have lied him like oh this is
fine scotch yes this is a this is
lagavulin 16 you know
okay guys what do you guys want to ask
me i uh pretty soon i'll have to walk
sawyer well he's being good and he's
actually laying hold on let me just show
you what he's doing so i'm in no rush
while he's doing that are you sawyer
oh i don't want to wake him
once he starts pestering me
then it'll be time for sure
um all right let's see
antarctica oh
um that's that's that's the next
frontier isn't it
all right someone asked me something
come on now keep me going here
i mean hold on
i don't want to miss anything have you
had any unexplained phenomena happen
to you while you were deployed not at
all not while deployed
not at all um
no
the one thing that comes to mind about
phenomena and no one i've told this
story before to some people i know and
so they always just brush it off but the
one thing i had with some phenomena
involved the dream that i had
i was living in boise
i was in a park this is when i first got
there was an apartment complex before i
went into a house
and i was sleeping facing the other
direction away from the window and i had
a dream that there was someone peeing
outside my window
of the bedroom
and i woke up facing
the other direction so not facing the
window
and
i basically just like the dream was so
powerful i'm like is there someone
outside my window right now what the
hell's going on you know you have a
dream you're like not sure if it's real
or not and i go and look outside my
window
and there's a dude walking up like
there's three people but one was close
to the window the other people just
they're just walking through this is not
even a path though it's not near the
sidewalk so they were walking through an
area where people shouldn't be but like
it was grass and some trees and it was
like along the fencing of the perimeter
of the apartment
and they came up next to the window and
then started pissing
that was one thing that like came to
mind when i was thinking about like
you know
intuitive moments before they happen
because i'm like what is the odds of
that and then i've told this story like
well maybe you heard them talking and
you knew he's gonna pee so it was kind
of your dream you thought your dream
like the freaking ac unit was on which
is right next to where he pissed it's
loud as hell he was like you know ac
unit compressor
i didn't hear anything i couldn't i
didn't hear him even when he was doing
it
that's now let me just say that's the
only time i've ever had some sort of
crazy dream like that but i don't know
what the hell
you know i i guarantee watch the
comments right now like oh you don't
know what you're talking about
um but anyways it's fun to share because
like it makes me wonder i'm like it
hasn't happened since i don't i'm not i
don't know i don't even know what to
think about it i just want i want to
wait for it to happen again
do you think there was a civilization in
the in antarctica
i'm very open to it
i'm waiting to see i think it's
incredibly possible especially when we
talk about pole shifts and other things
and adam and eve story it is so possible
and i find it very interesting there's
so much stuff going on down there with
all these countries from around the
world
it's very possible that there's just a
lot of precious resources there that
they're expecting to find under the ice
whether it's oil or precious metals and
minerals
and maybe that's all why the reason why
the you know the powers to be around the
world or countries i should say
want to be there and are there
but whether there are civilizations
i'm
i want to believe it
but it's like you know how long ago has
some of that ice been there i think some
of the dice is more recent than some all
right because here's the thing what
about the perry reese map doesn't the
pierce map show some parts of antarctica
that are now under ice but weren't then
but they know it's there just because
our technological abilities today to
understand that that's what the land
looks like underneath the ice if that's
all the case then
well what the hell like people live all
over the place they just this is what
humans do they travel around and they
live all right home let me read some of
these super chats
magus galsu have you looked into the
mali empire taking all the gold from
atlantis no
but i know that atlanta says to have
gold and mali and those other parts of
africa have gold so let me dig into that
a little bit and i mean no mauritania
has gold it's one of its uh highest
exports or among them i should say
um
yeah there's something to be said for
that i think
sky watchers sun and well it cuts off
after that but thank you so much for the
super sticker
and we got harry white here why didn't
you take ayahuasca with ben in peru and
you should look into ce5 all right so
let me make a note about ce5
and to be honest with you
so here's the thing about the ayahuasca
situation
that is so high on my list to do
but i was on a tour and i would have had
to stay in country longer
and
i got to be honest with you that is like
doing an ayahuasca journey like a four
night thing
is so high on my list and it has been
for years but it just this particular
time down to peru which is such a shame
because while you're there it's like one
in rome you got to do these things but i
think the best thing would be for me
to to do that in a trip like that
solely for that reason not like oh hey
i'm traveling because you got to keep
mine when it comes to luggage and other
things i'm bringing all this camera
stuff i'm traveling and bringing a tire
for traveling and for going to sites and
all this stuff
and
i think an ayahuasca journey needs to be
like me and one other person and it's
like literally a soul i gotta go there
expecting to have a lot of down time to
just spend all day thinking about my
experience from the night before
anticipating doing the next night's
ayahuasca ceremony because that's what i
want to do i want to do four nights in a
row minimum that's what i would like to
do because that's what a lot of people
have recommended to have a profound
experience
so it's kind of a shame going down there
and not doing it but i
i believe i just need to do it um oh
linfest you're going if i sell this
right latar it don't let me send
questions feed censored what but then
you send this
another 249 check
but it's good night it is a good night
and i'm you've been extremely generous
hit me up on instagram or send me an
email you are wonderful
rob
weisenhunt
drink what you want it's okay to like
things i'd love to buy you a few and
chat someday have fun and be safe in
egypt thank you brother all right so
anyone that's on this
uh live stream that wasn't here in the
beginning let me just say a couple
things
that i said earlier on that you may have
not heard one of which is that i file i
fly out to egypt next wednesday
and on friday october 1st a week from
today i will be doing a live stream from
the giza plateau i have the appropriate
equipment i believe that will be able to
be done
the
connection involving 3g that they had
out there it might be 4g now or 5g uh
because i imagine they'd skip over 4g at
this point when i was there last year
was all 3g but the service was excellent
on the plateau i mean i had instant
texas it was there was no delay
i want to believe the connection will be
good assuming all goes well i mean worst
case scenario i just film on my other
cameras and i upload later but the plan
is to do a complete
giza plateau tour and i'm talking around
the sphinx all the pyramids and showing
you all the other sites and i especially
want to go around all those damn lock
doors and gates they have all over the
plateau and filming like live like look
at this
this is what i'm talking about see this
lock gate um
and i also want to show you just the
various huge structures and massive
stone cut blocks that you've never seen
or heard about or at least that most
people haven't because we've all seen
and heard about the sphinx and the
pyramids but most people have no idea
all the other incredible structures that
are right there
and it's not like guys i had been
studying egypt for a couple years few
years five years before i even got there
and i'm like
or even as a kid because that's how i
fell in love was in the sixth grade when
i learned about it and i'm like getting
out there in the first five ten minutes
i'm like
whoa this isn't how i thought this was
laid out this is interesting learning
things like that like that like that and
because so many of you um
you know many people in the world won't
have the opportunity to travel to egypt
or it could be a long time before you do
i want you to live vicariously through
me and my camera since i'm blessed
enough to be able to get out there
the best thing i can do is at least show
you through my own eyes and if i could
do a complete tour of the giza plateau
which will take hours
it would be i think it
epic next level epic so i really want to
do that um
let's see here who else has some
questions here
do you still wear your molded knife
moldavite necklace uh no it broke but i
still have it and i'll never get rid of
it i think it was wonderful
i have it a broken half but it's still
intact through the pendant that it's
held on
i still think there's something to it
but it could just be the power of the
leaf like placebo is a real thing
um okay all right here we go i just got
the the battery low battery comment hold
on i'm at 20 percent i got a little bit
longer right all right so let me go for
another if i'm at 20 let's just say let
me go for another i'm having fun i'm in
no rush
i kind of got to pee but my uh
dog sawyer is doing okay and it's really
dependent on him i fed him before the
live stream and
um
i just want to take him on a walk that's
my plan for this evening
anyway so let's say another 20 minutes
30 max but that seems like a little bit
of a while so maybe i'll wrap this up in
10-15 minutes it depends if you guys
want to keep me around send me some
super chat questions
um
but anyways going back to the moldavite
the power belief in placebo is a real
thing and placebo is power belief and
now this is a scientific fact it is
unexplained how placebo works which is
that when they do various they give
people various placebos people have been
cured from various different elements
from the power of believing they have
received something that would fix them
how do you explain that this has
happened time and time again and it's
happening with multiple different
ailments and diseases
it is unexplainable it is unknown to
science just like
how let me give you an easier example
it's known that like you know the power
of laughter and humor you know and you
know
increasing someone's spirits can help
them heal that's known um
positivity is a good thing
so i think that this all ties into what
i was talking earlier with law of
attraction and other things um
which is that belief i think this is
what the bible meant i used to think it
it meant you know pass around the
collection plate and put money in it
like i said earlier
i think now it might have to do with the
power of the human mind and the power of
belief is how all these magnificent
people throughout history believe they
could do something
you know
so let's see here what else we got
someone wrote oh thank you ray for the
super chat
if anyone has any other i'm looking
okay here we go rey portela i'm a young
adult and just coming out of high school
i want to pursue archaeology but i don't
know the best route do you have any
advice on how to get into dig sites and
start researching oh man all right this
is extremely tough because most
archaeologists a vast
overwhelming majority of archaeologists
don't ever get to dig anything ever
it's super sad too because like they
should be allowed to that's what i want
them to do i'm on their side i don't
care what they believe if they believe
there's no ancient any you know
technology
don't matter to me just go dig and show
me what you find that's all i want just
show me what you find and do it
it's like i was talking earlier in this
live stream about go back to tepe
what's going on there you know they
rediscovered the site 20 plus years ago
or longer
what year are we in now 25 plus years
ago
and we're still we have barely made any
headway like what the hell is going on
like unreal
so okay so to answer your question
if you have a total desire to go there
and dig then you can make it happen
if some archaeologist can get into dig
sites then you can too you got to figure
out what it takes to make that happen
right
so
um
i don't know man i saw some recent
article that was following around about
how some universities are going to cut
back on archaeology degrees like they're
eliminating it
this is like
a two days ago
it's extremely concerning
let me give you let me just give you
another idea here i am on youtube i'm
helping bringing mysteries of ancient
civilization to light whether i'm right
or wrong on things it doesn't even
matter i developed a following and found
a means of living
and and bringing information to others
and i did it all by myself
so it's all about creativity but you
know when it comes to digging things up
you know there's government regular i
mean you you can't just go out and dig
you'll
you know because spend the rest of your
life in prison or some crap you know
ah if i were you i would right here's
what i would recommend doing find out
what archaeologists have been to the
notable sites whether it's go back to
tepe
um i won't include egypt because that's
all so government-run no ain't nobody
going in there today unless they are
affiliated and have the permissions and
other things
um but i would i would research any
more recent archaeological digs that
have happened in say the last 10 years
find out who's physically done that
find out their email addresses because
they're probably academics or whoever
and just ask like hey i want to be an
archaeologist but i want to do it
with the the prospect of digging someday
and find out how to make that happen or
what their best advice is and go from
there
that's my best advice find out who else
has already done it recently not 20
years ago the world is changing very
quickly and like andrew just said from
ancient uh um
uh historical criticisms uh ancient
history criticisms go subscribe to him
you know there's truth there and i i'm
starting to think guys that maybe
everything's going to be government run
now well then maybe that means you need
to become a government archaeologist of
some kind someone that gets that federal
funding maybe that's what you need to do
well there is a will there is a way now
hold on i'm seeing other super chats
here
we got oh we got kira again oh my god
you're so generous
jimmy isn't it uh just one thing anyways
do you know nikola tesla and swami uh
i always mess up this name we're friends
i did not me i don't know if i knew that
actually
you should listen to read what
uh in raja yoga what they all said do
you think you would find value based on
the subjects you have spoken about
tonight yeah i don't think it's an
accident hang on because i'm gonna make
a note make another one i made one
earlier for the other comment
that way
i definitely go down this rabbit hole
stormy
tesla
thanks sweetheart
extremely generous too by the way
because who knows what that rabbit hole
that's gonna lead me down i didn't know
that if i knew this i knew it five years
ago i've since forgotten
i don't feel like i knew this at all now
when i go and read on it and and do some
googling and seeing the connections
there if i see anything that rings bell
then i'm like oh okay i did hear this
thank you so much um dustin harry i've
been diving into christianity and the
origin of the religion gnosticism is
very intriguing with its pursuit of
knowledge have you studied do you study
religion well actually to be honest with
you i have a minor in religious studies
which was so awesome i've always been
curious about world religions
and then when i was getting my undergrad
i wanted to get some gpa boosters so i'm
like all right let me let me establish a
minor and i'll i'll do electives
essentially
and or or
orient
basically take the take up the minor as
an elective way of boosting my gpa and i
was like i need to choose the most
interesting things possible because i'll
do better in the subject if i'm actually
interested
and it turned it worked out so well in a
couple ways one is because the
at least all right so i was going to asu
arizona state university and at that
time i don't know if it's still the same
but it was super easy for some of these
courses to get a pluses which is a big
deal for boosting a gpa
and uh just the way the courses were
laid out i don't know if i should brag
about i don't really care i'll just tell
you hey if you guys need a gpa booster
there just go to ratemyprofessor.com
and you can look up there's some there's
certain teachers that do discussion
board posts exclusively which basically
means that they'll sign you a chapter in
a book a textbook and then you're
required to
write out three paragraphs describe you
know explaining each one of these three
little topics within the that particular
chapter or something so easy if you do
it you get credit
a plus
but in the process i learned a ton of
stuff on a topic i was already
interested in so i learned about all
kinds of religions across the world and
uh sorry that was my uh
that was my
i'm using a
lavalier mic here
and it knocked when i swiped with my
aggressive hand motion
i totally knocked my phone off i think i
did that when i did my post egypt
uh live stream last december
that woke sawyer up it scared him
hi sawyer
hi buddy he's getting ready all right
guys just a few more minutes because i
should head out with sawyer but we still
got 900 plus people so
who else has another yet someone wrote
take another swig sure
drunk ass just throwing this
freaking damn thing on there i'm not i'm
only slightly buzzed guys i'm not drunk
i'm below the legal limit i could say
that for sure
i'm going driving right after this
that's a joke
um
but it's so funny anytime i drink on
these live streams you know people like
i see the comments like drunkard what
are you doing like
i didn't pre-game it before this one
um all right so let's see here let jimmy
white fork wasted love my ass off god i
love these comments this is one of the
funnest things
so that's your fifth glass man
it really isn't it's my second
um you guys are wonderful i'd say the
juice
should i end the live stream on my
hammered
um
somebody asked me a question here
because i'm having fun
do some drop shots oh my god here we go
don't hit jimmy oh this is so funny
thanks for you
thank uh hang buick thank you so much
thanks for your channel can't get enough
of what you discussed i really
appreciate that
jimmy the moon is the moon hollow okay
probably
there's there is certain scientific
evidence that strongly suggests it now
whether it's hollow because of
intelligent design or something natural
we don't understand
i bet on it and and here's how we know
or would suggest it
the for example the apollo moon missions
on all the missions they brought over
seismic seismographs and so in the five
how many times did we go there five
times um and yeah because they're
supposed to be six and the apollo 13
fell apart anyways every time we went
there we placed various seismic glass
grafts around and have since observed
and still do today various earthquakes
that happen now the fact that the moon
has earthquakes i think is interesting
because isn't supposed to be a dead
planet why is it still having
earthquakes but there could be other
things to explain that regardless when
they threw the saturn v uh launch
vehicle or whatever it was into it on
purpose in order to measure the
seismographs this is back in the 70s
they
annotated and this happened to more than
one occasion uh twice they annotated
this which is that the moon reverberated
like they described it as ringing like a
bell and that the seismic reverberations
between all the seismographs across you
know the various areas they put it went
on for hours and hours on end and it
just indicated that perhaps there was a
cavity of some kind or size within the
center of the moon or whatever
there are other interesting things about
it as well such as that the uh craters
of the moon are far more wide than they
are shallow google that that's something
easy you could check for yourself or you
could google actually moon seismic
activity type in the satisf saturn v
launch vehicle he threw into it and then
look into with your own eyes just google
craters of the moon or whatever
um well don't do craters in the moon
they'll bring up a a natural uh park in
idaho that's what it's called but anyway
look into it and it there are very smart
people that have just simply asked
questions saying well that's interesting
why are they so wide and so shallow just
look into it and what now if you want to
go down the conspiracy and the crazy
part of it some people think that is a
hollowed-out planetoid
the reason why the moon is so shiny or
shiny is because of the metallic uh
substance which is the reason why it
reflects and it's so white um and people
say that it's metal shavings from
whatever side the you know maybe the
iron or whatever the core was being
metallic and that it was purposely
hollowed out and that it was a space
vehicle
and it was brought here and meant to be
the because you got to keep in mind
there's certain other things about it
the the mass of itself is completely
unnatural for the size of it in that
it's um one-fifth the size of planet
earth but it's like something like one
i'm going to get the number wrong but i
want to say 180th
the mass that it should be or whatever
it was
um so it's unbelievably light for what
it should be based on our current
knowledge now maybe that's a completely
natural explanation that we don't yet
understand
or
could it be evidence
of a long lost
intelligent design that goes back who
knows how long
i wonder that and i pro i kind of think
because i think there's something about
the moon there's this huge rush to go
mine there but yeah it's all in the dl
it's really weird
um hold on we got a super chat here i
don't want to miss
rico hirano
i said that wrong saskino forgive me
rico will say thanks uh bringing up
neville goddard i think he is legitimate
but i haven't quite figured it out
sounds like you did
listen to his lectures go on youtube and
type type in neville goddard
um
imagination or divine imagination things
like that um
and just neville goddard lectures and
just there's numerous ones but maybe
look into ones but he's on view count
kind of get an idea what he's about
i think he nailed it that's what i think
because he's saying things that i
already thought on my own from my own
time in isolation of living alone and
just dabbling in the spiritual realm and
doing my own studies of what the
ancients said and dabbling into law of
attraction and all this other stuff and
to me i'm like how have i never heard of
this guy
and he's saying things to me that make a
lot of sense and i think that his
argument the bible has been
vastly misinterpreted i suspect he's
onto something i really do i could be
wrong but if nothing else check him out
and think for yourselves guys
okay rob weisenhunt welcome back p.s
please share anything you find
about the resonant and acoustic
acoustical properties of the pyramids
and other structures thank you thank you
um yeah it's wild man i've never heard
anything like it even being inside the
uh
the so-called king's chamber of the
great pyramid i've never heard anything
like it a whisper
like goes back and forth it's like
nothing else now of course it's granite
and stone is gonna bounce sound back and
forth it's like nothing else but the
question is was this stuff used for
healing and i'm not necessarily saying
the pyramid but there's been other sites
too all over whether it's peru and other
sites around egypt we all have acoustic
properties to them which are
interesting it's like was this
on purpose was it intentional to make
that happen or is it just a byproduct of
just the design itself i think there's
something to it
um what else do you guys got
because i'll have to wrap this up a
little bit once my phone says ten
percent i'll probably bail and plus i do
got to use the bathroom but i don't
wanna i don't wanna take the the break
to do it i rather just keep going and
right now we're at i'm at 187 minutes
wait am i
at three hours oh my god i am
it's 6 41 p.m and i started this like at
six or excuse me 3 35 or so p.m i can't
believe i just did three hours
i've had so much fun man maybe i should
talk for a living more often
do you guys think i should do live all
right here's a fun thing i'll wrap this
up unless there's any other super chat
super chats will keep me here i'm not
going to deny that
um
so
do you guys think i should do some live
speaking engagements of some kind maybe
tour around i mean i could start small i
don't know whether it's and there's
different venues i could do i could set
it up myself or whatever would you guys
think there's
i mean i like to speak in person let me
say that i think it's incredibly
thrilling
uh when i was in the military and in the
corporate world i was a trained the
trainer in both settings so i did i did
you know in-person speaking and i also
got an undergrad in communications and
so of course i had to do public speaking
coursework for that so we had to give
presentations and as well as when i went
back to school it was required every
single course required in the program
for the mba uh to do presentations in
front of the class
and i love it it is something really
exciting about it um
i i just like speaking in person
and
i guess i'm answering my own question i
should totally do this huh i think it'd
be fun and i think i'm better at
speaking in person than i am on camera
i've had to improve my camera work
because it's kind of awkward i mean i
like talking in front of the camera but
it is awkward i feel like i can feed off
an audience way better than this
uh there's something very inclusive
about it
so
um
thanks diddy i love you too have a thank
you
did your amazing uh who else we got here
but anyways all right so you guys are
saying yes all right i should totally do
it yeah do vegas
live from the mgm grand or maybe no
circus circus then maybe they'll allow
me to come in there and talk
all right guys let's see here anything
else
um here your super chat's still up here
at the top those 50 ones hang in there
for a long time
it's laid out by minutes i should
probably figure out how this works like
a dollar lasts for a certain period of
time five dollars less for a certain
period time they're all space and the
more you leave the longer it stays up
there i need to start prioritizing now
that i understand how this works that to
the lower dollar amounts to read off
first
um
yeah sorry anthony circus circus
laughing my ass if i know right
i go there or maybe the stratosphere
since my ideas are so through the
atmosphere so through the roof
all right well
since i'm well over three hours i can't
believe it that's how i know i should
probably be doing something like this
live and that if it feels fun to go
um chat for hours on end and for it to
feel so quick
maybe that's something that i should
really dive into so
any other thoughts guys um someone keeps
asking me david wilcock i don't know i
don't want to say anything i don't know
i haven't met him i don't know i've i
remember reading one of his books on
audio a long time ago when i was first
dabbling into the spiritual realm
um this is like they say 2015 or 16. um
so i don't know i'd have to have to get
to i don't know um
uh what the hell is this webcams hot
girls and boys hold on
hide user from channel
blocked
remove i should report this
remove
perverts
glad i saw that
anyways guys i guess i'll wrap this up
if there's any others if anyone has
anything else they want to say if you
want to be the last super chat of the
night leave it now
um otherwise i'm super grateful you guys
are wonderful so just for everybody
that's uh
hasn't heard earlier a week from today
friday i'm doing a live stream from the
giza plateau it's going to be epic
assuming everything goes well with the
connection
i believe that it will i'm set up for it
and uh i'm gonna give you guys a tour of
the plateau like you've never seen
before i'm gonna walk around as best as
i can and um
oh hold on you did it again
what is your name is it ladder or is
that just a acronym ladder
lindsfist you are a true gentleman very
very sweet of you
all right guys if there's any others um
but
i guess i'll wrap this up here yep oh
hold on i know that it's time because my
phone just said ten percent i said i'd
wrap it up now i'm at
191 minutes so well over three hours so
you guys are great say bye don't keep me
here any longer you're gonna go like
sawyer even though he's walking oh hold
on
i perceive myself as gunky you're really
cool you're really cool that's very nice
of you
um
all right guys i'm wrapping this up
thank you so much for all your support
you guys are very generous and i'm very
grateful
and i'm gonna i'm gonna end this now
let's see here
all right
bye everybody